Hi
Ron.
I know.
Okay.
I like to leave people in
suspense. What's up fuckers? Hey,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is brought to you by nature box.
Do you hear that?
Munchen in the background.
That is the hilarious Hannibal Buress
beating some naturebox and it is yummy is
pretty. It's pretty good. I'm
not even getting paid for this.
Paid Burris sour cream and onion almost.
Yeah,
I get all the gluten free ones. Then
I tried to get the healthiest version.
They have healthy up to eh kind
of sketchy, healthy but delicious.
All delicious like pretzels. You can't
really make pretzels healthy. Sorry folks.
That's not really possible.
It's made it a bread unless you come
up with some rice pretzels. Anyway.
Point is what they do have is delicious.
The Blueberry Almond,
so you've got to try that shit.
That's my favorite.
My second favorite is these dark cocoa
almonds. God Damn, those are good.
Woo.
Their products are all natural.
They combine a much higher quality
ingredient than a typical vending machine.
Ingredients makes them healthier.
They have a hundred snacks to choose from.
So if you're looking for something that
like if you have certain dietary needs,
like your gluten free, low
sugar content, stuff like that,
they have that too whenever possible.
They also tried to use non
GMO food as well. You know,
GMO food is a very hot topic.
You want to say you're organic and GMO.
No one knows what either
one of those things mean,
you know there's a lot of
genetically modified food folks.
Essentially all almost all corn you eat,
almost all wheat you eat
is genetically modified,
especially wheat because it's like
the 1950s they changed the shit.
That's why people are
so gluten intolerant.
But g m o really genetically modified
did like, you know, fucking lab.
That's the new shit. Yeah. You knew
you were scared. You really no food.
Joe Ran a little bit of food and a
breast just a little bit. Anyway,
no high fructose corn syrup.
No partially hydrogenated oils,
no trans fats, no artificial
sweeteners, no artificial flavors,
no artificial colors.
So they make their shit.
It's healthy as possible and still yummy.
I think it's a good balance
between, you know, eaten raw kale,
which I do a lot of,
and having these delicious cocoa almonds.
So anyway,
naturebox.com uh,
we support them, they support
the podcast and uh, I enjoy them.
And if you go to naturebox.com/rogan,
you will get 50% off your first box.
That's a pretty sweet deal. Bitches,
50% half off your first box.
Go to naturebox.com forward slash Rogen
and free shipping anywhere in the u s so
naturebox is busting up to vending
machines, monopoly on your mid day hunger.
That's obviously someone else wrote that,
not me. You can tell the difference.
Slacking a certain something.
Anyway,
naturebox.com/rogan go there.
Enjoy it.
We're also brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com that's o, n n I t,
makers of Alpha, brain tech,
new mood, all controversial,
new tropics and performance enhancing
drugs that are legal. Um, what,
what is Alpha brain,
if you've never heard of it before?
Alpha brain is what's called a nootropic
and Google, Google that word, and Oh,
tropic.
And what it is is essentially nutrients
that give your brain the building blocks
it needs to produce
human neurotransmitter's.
It's very complicated stuff obviously.
Yeah, it was actually first formulated,
I think Prasad,
Tim was one of the first and it was
in the 1960s they figured this out.
They figured out that it changes
or levels of Acetylcholine,
acetylcholine enhances
memory. For me, the big one,
what it does best is allows
me to pull up words like,
I feel like it allows me to form
sentences more freely. And you know,
there's actually been
scientific studies done on it,
both in individual ingredients and
there's recently been a clinical trial on
Alpha brain.
All the,
all the lab results are
all posted@onnit.com uh,
if you go to Alpha brain, the
click on that link, you can,
you can read the clinical results. We
did one study, we got positive results,
especially on a memory and a execution.
I have to be able to be able to
execute tasks and think about things.
And it's sort of like
what I'm saying with, with
formulating sentences like this,
there's a direct effect between how you
can formulate sentences and how much
nutrition you've had. I mean,
it just makes sense. I mean,
do you feel better when you have more
nutrition? Of course you do. Have,
you feel better.
Probably your brain feels better too.
That's the idea behind the Alpha brain.
Very controversial.
So with all controversial ingredients,
all the controversial, uh,
supplements that we sell it on it,
we have a 100% money back guarantee.
You don't have to return the pills.
The first 30 pills you buy first bottle,
you have 90 days. Try it. If you say
it sucks, you get your money back.
It's that simple.
And the idea being that we're only
selling you some shit that we know works.
There's scientific data
behind it. I use it. Aubrey,
who's my partner and CEO of on it,
he uses it.
A ton of athletes use it,
including Bodie Miller,
a j Hawk dudes who know
their body very well.
Supplements man, fuck gas branch and do
you know what I'm doing, Hannibal Burress.
I'm out there trying to, trying to
spread everything that I learned.
If I find interesting shit, I try to,
I try to sell it the way to do it.
That's it's like ethical economics anyway,
on a.com.
Use the Codeword Rogan save 10%
off any and all supplements, uh,
that does not apply to strength
and conditioning equipment.
Let's just all expensive for selling
cannonballs and shipping them through the
mail. So, uh, go there. Enjoy
Hannibal Burress is here.
Young Jamie Cuban music.
Hello.
Oh, you fucked up, son froze. Itunes
froze. Don't be blaming iTunes, man.
It's just fucking computer
for the 1990s that I have.
Okay.
The Joe Rogan experience.
When people get silly,
stupid shit that's on the list there.
Experience
Joe Rogan podcast.
My Name,
ladies and gentlemen,
what the fuck
rest is here, ladies and
gentlemen? What's up? I like a,
I like meeting a Jude who I,
I only know you by your comedy
actually bought your comedy.
I listened to it on the way home from
Irvine and laughed my ass off and then
meeting you and just within minutes
we're talking on the air. I like that.
That's the best way to do it. This
is the best way to do it. Yeah.
Thanks for having me. Hey, thanks
for doing it man. I'm excited. Uh,
that you have products and stuff.
That's good to branch out, dude.
It's all shit that I'm interested in.
Let's try it again.
I tried to keep myself interested.
I think that the,
I feel different when I get excited about
something like a new exercise or a new
hobby I'm trying or anything.
I get excited when I'm in,
so I try to spread that.
Yeah.
As much as I can because I tried to
think I want to get into other aspects of
businesses and that's cool that you done
stuff that, that you're interested in.
Because I like comedy. I talk about
this and Matt like light comedy,
but I understand that is fleeting.
So if everything in comedy with a way
for you got supplements is shit. Yeah,
but I don't think comedy is fleeting.
He really thinks,
I think it's like one of the
least fleeting, whichever leading.
But I'm just saying maintenance.
It needs maiden but then cause a in the
business like I'm talking about where
you know, stuff might be going well, but
then uh, you not work it as much anymore.
I got a theory about that. I think
that shits in the past. Yeah.
I don't think that's
going to happen anymore.
I think guys would go away because
they wouldn't get gigs anymore.
They wouldn't get television shows,
they wouldn't get all these things.
But now everybody promotes themselves.
They all, everybody has a Twitter account.
Everybody has a website.
Everybody,
when you get fans now they know where
they can find you. Yeah. It used to be,
if you weren't on television where,
hey, where'd he go? Where's this guy?
Where did he go?
It vanished.
You can't just go to his Facebook page
and read a blog that he wrote today.
That's fucking hilarious.
You know,
you can't go and watch a youtube clip
that he made when he was fucking around
his backyard with his dog. It's
hilarious. All that shit is new. Oh,
you know, I don't confident. I'm totally
100% confident. That's comforting.
You're going anywhere. Hannibal
Burress, but the top [inaudible].
You've inspired me to get my tiny bottles
of lotion for hotels business going
because that's what I'm passionate about.
I'm passionate about tidy bottles of
lotion and that seems like a stable
business. People use it. I want to
get in that. Yeah, people do use it.
Someone's got to be selling them
that shit. Yeah, that's a good point.
I want to get into that.
You have some better smelling stuff that
a smell and stuff and maybe some jokes
on the lotion. That's a good
apple style with lotion. Oh Man.
Too funny though.
You don't want to do jerking off with
your lotion and cracking up. No. Yeah,
not that you don't want to be
in the middle of it so you
don't lose your stroke.
You don't want to do loses his stroke
when you go limp while jerking off. Man,
those are tough.
Again,
it up again while you jerking off what ss.
A lot of work,
but that's just if you focused,
if you really,
if you're really about making it to
your goal, then you just power through.
That's really what it is.
It seems frivolous,
but it's really just an
exercise and achieving your
goals. Fall down nine times.
Get up nine times.
Why did I say they say get up 10
what the fuck are you talking about?
It's because people fall down
and lock your brain damage. You
can't just fall down nine times she got
fucked up, man. Little kids fall down.
They hurts themselves. But you're a grown
man. You gotta Fall Down Nine Times.
You're not gonna break something.
Why are you falling? So what's that?
What's your balance? Are you getting
tackled or you just straight up falling?
You've got a bum Nissan. No ankle
week. You've got a weak foot. Yeah,
people got to get it together.
Fall down nine times.
Get up 10 what are you saying? How does
that even work? It does it. I don't know.
I guess get up in the morning,
getting up in the morning.
That's what they count and count that
because you get to count line down in bed
then too. That's fallen down. Yeah, they
gave a bitch. You went to sleep? Yeah man.
So basically what I'm saying is
fuck that old way, way commercial.
I've been, that's what I came here. So
thank you. I'm glad you're here man.
Promote naturebox and say fuck that
stupid commercial. Yeah, congrats.
The nature box. There's congrats to them.
Cause this, this is pretty new company,
right? Well is it? Yeah, I think so.
Honestly don't know too much about him
other than their stuff. Taste good.
But yeah, I mean I know it's
cheesy and you know, Oh,
you'll philosophical quote shit.
But this was an idea and is now is good.
And his hair. Yeah. I like when anybody
comes up with anything. That's
a good idea. It's interesting.
It's interesting to see new companies
sprout out because of the Internet to like
this business is now, he could
have never had it. Like today,
if you ever want an excuse to start
your own business, today's the fuck.
Like here's this company vehement knives.
They make homemade knives. They sent me,
they made me a knife,
beautiful handcrafted knife.
Like they sent me a video of how
they made it. Right then it's like,
it's beautiful, handcrafted
artisan ship. You know. I mean,
I didn't really need a knife,
but it's cool as fuck that somebody
would do that and it's cool as fuck that.
These guys who are listening to the
podcast, their podcast listeners,
they came up with an idea for company
and they started doing it and now it's
there. That's their job.
That's their business.
They don't have to work for anybody.
That was awesome. Making your own shit,
making, making knives or whatever.
Making old record players.
Who knows the fuck you want to make.
What you going to do with
that knife that night?
Just like so it's going to sit
around my house and look cool.
It's like a trophy wife. You never fucked,
you know one of those just sit around.
It looks sporty. No, I'll
take it somewhere. Maybe take
it hunting things go hard.
We wrong. I might need it. Yeah. You know,
you get attacked by something out in
the wild. You gotta defend yourself.
I have plans, I strategies in my head
like what I would do from mountain.
Mine jumped me.
It was fucking me up.
I have like an idea in my head
or how I'd fight it with a knife.
Yeah, because where to hit it at? Where'd
you hit it with the knife first,
which you get in the face and the gut.
You've got to give the animal something
to bite onto. That's very important.
You've got to put something in front of
the animal so that it bites that before
applying to you. So bites the
first thing. Get instinctively.
That's when he stabbed in the neck.
That's what I'm saying.
That's a great strategy.
I think that's the only strategy you
gotta be willing to sacrifice one of your
arms though. Your arms going to
get mauled. Cause I couldn't,
I'm pretty logical, but at times
I'm a rational and delusional.
So I think that I could knock out
a mountain lion with a two hit cop,
two hit Combo and I
hit him with the right.
Hit Him with the left and I'm stepping
back to the young man confidence.
Your punching power
plant. My feet house cat.
I'm trying to knock out a house.
A house cat can take a fucking tremendous
punch. Really very rare. They go out.
Well, I never punched a cat. What?
I did watch a cat jump from a
tree and it just stuck in a tree.
I mean this fucking cat must have
fallen like 30 feet, hit the ground,
Bam. And started running.
I mean it was unbelievable.
I thought the cat was dead for sure.
I was watching the cat started
running and hit the ground.
It's a video is a video of it on youtube.
I saw it online.
The cat hits the ground and
fucking takes off at full clip.
Doesn't go whoa, hold up. What the
fuck just happened? Cat fell 30 feet,
which is approximately like, what would
that be for a person? I don't know.
Six foot tall person falling 30 feet.
It'd be terrible compared to a cat.
Cat is four inches high. Yeah. Fell
that far and it was fine. That's crazy.
Cause I can't even walk right away.
If I had like a huge Fart,
I still kinda got to, I can't. I
got a little bit, yeah, get shaky.
Shaky of, yeah. It's all
good for that cat food.
Just be it. I think they have really
flexible bones. Don't think cats.
Cats like they, uh, you know, they're
built different than us. Yeah, they can.
They can definitely take
impacts. We can't, right.
My point is I don't think the left right
going to work. I don't think it would.
You might have to get the, I
clench the knees techniques.
Yeah. Here's the cat. Watch
his fucking cat is kept.
Falls out of his fucking tree,
man. You like that cat's dead. Right.
Okay. First of all, I said 30 feet.
That shit's way higher than 30 feet. 80
feet. Look at that. Boom and then see ya.
And the cat runs off the feet.
The cat fell 80 feet. Okay.
That's just a different thing.
They're just way different than us.
Look at that cat's fine. That cat
is broken up, but is this shock?
You might be right. I might be right.
I mean, look at that shit though, man.
Oof. Did it follow this? It's like a fell
out. It's back. Yeah. That's a shitty cat.
Cat is broken up. That's a
shitty cat. I thought. Cat.
So he's filling their fat cat.
That cat had human like self consciousness
where you know how we fuck that.
I'm cool. I'm cool. That's what that
cat was doing. That cat isn't that fine?
I think you're probably right. And you
notice it hit the and the way down.
I bet it got knocked the fuck out, but
that's what happened. I bet it got dazed.
He'd probably crack one of those branches
and then maybe that that's what helped
it survive. Maybe gain k owed
by the branch. Like watch this
man. Did it hit a branch? Yeah.
I wonder what part hit the branch and
then they ran under the car. Yeah.
Okay. That's good bank. Yeah.
Yeah. See it. Bam. Yeah, it
definitely hit that tree.
At least it looks like in that
perspective. Poor cat. Anyway,
he's fine amount of lines like
that, but bigger. In fact,
they say that like house cats and
mountain lions are very similar in their
amount of power. You know like what
they can generate pound of body weight,
which is pretty fucking crazy when you
think that a mountain lion is out there
running around like a 50 pound mountain
line would fucking kill you easy then.
Yeah,
that would be a bummer the way to do you
go into woods and hunt and stuff like
that? Yeah, I've been doing that recently.
But when you go there in the
woods hunting, you're armed.
You're not worried nearly
as much as if you're hiking.
You go in California
where you go? No, I have,
well I've been pig hunting in California.
Went wild pig hunting did once it
have been a Wisconsin and Montana,
the two places in Montana has been
the only place I camped out outside.
And do you have a hundred and crew?
Was it other comics? So as you got,
what would Brian Cowen, yeah,
yeah. I went with him twice.
We didn't go pig hunting together. I went
out with another guy. I went with this,
there's a guy named Steve Rinella and a,
he's got this TV show called
meat eater and he's a hunter.
He took us hunting and I got hooked
on it. Really do. Fascinating Shit.
Do you eat the stuff you hunted? Yeah,
I try and I'm trying to only eat that.
That's what I'm trying to depression.
I'm process. Yeah. I mean it's,
it's a hundred percent organic
except footed lit. Yeah.
You don't have to keep showing that pig
that's a photo of the pig murdered it.
He can't say murder
cause it's not a person.
I suppose to say harvest
harvest makes it sound better.
That's still like killing an animal.
But you kill an animal every time you eat
a ham sandwich. Harvest tomatoes. Yeah.
Well they think of it as crops, not its
crops, but as you know, something you're,
you're getting out of the earth. You
know, harvesting an animal from the earth,
bringing it home and eating it. I'm
trying to only eat that at home, you know,
I just think there's a lot of bad
Karma attached to factory farming.
I just think I'd like meat. I don't
want to give up the idea of eating meat,
but the eye and you watch those videos
and people could say all they want about
that's, you know, a
fraction of those, you know,
of those animals get treated like that.
Most animals get treated
ethically and humanely.
I drive a friend who has a farm
and he raises a grass fed beef.
He raises these beef for slaughter.
They have a full pasture,
the grazing and they, you know, they're
out there eating grass, no hormones,
no antibiotics, no nothing. Those
cats, those, they're scared as fuck.
I'll give you go anywhere near those
cows. Those cows freak out. You know why?
Because they know we're killers and
we're going to eat them eventually and
they're trapped in this cage. Like the
idea that it's way better, it's better.
It's definitely better. Most of the time
it's better, but it's still a freak out.
They're still trapped.
Well,
just a lot in life they took given
they were given it a lot in life.
That's a Saki lot in life.
It is.
But so you so use this though because
hunting is just doing the same thing but
on a, on a more base level,
just on a smaller level
in a way. Yeah. You just doing it. I mean,
you cutting out the middleman
and you're cutting out,
you're cutting out the middle man in
the animals living completely wild.
This is like a concept behind hunting
that certain types of people do.
It's called fair chase.
Yeah.
And what that means is that you're not
dealing with an fenced in environment
that you're only hunting and an
animal that's truly wild, wild animal.
They can go wherever it wants.
So in order to harvest this animal,
you have to figure out how to get close
enough to it. You've got to stock it,
you got a, you know, you got to
understand where the wind's blowing.
Like there's a lot of factors involved.
And when you take that animal,
most likely that an animal would not have
even known you existed until it died,
like out of nowhere. It just dies.
Right. And it's the most ethical way.
But that animal's still scared as fuck.
If it sees a person and the reason being,
because there's people like
me that will shoot it. Right.
No, I see. That was and that
bit, you know, just chilling out,
waiting to and has seen it.
It hasn't just seen his friends
be slaughtered and hung up.
Yeah. It's not trapped. Yeah.
You know, it's a wild animal.
You're going out and getting a wild
animal, but it's also a wild animal.
That's most of the time they're aware
of people and then they don't want to be
anywhere near us. Yeah. The,
the real tripper is when you can go
and you could see a wild animal that
probably never saw a fucking human being
like go up to the Yukon or some shit.
Yeah. And then they freak
out. Or they, they don't even
know what the fuck you are.
A caribou. Caribou will just look
at you like, what the fuck is this?
Sometimes antelopes will come towards
people because they don't know what the
fuck they are. Yeah. They're
like, what the fuck are you,
I never seen when you were four
and then point blank. Yeah.
Well not that close. You just don't get
that close, but they will look at you.
But sometimes antelopes had been
encountered people and sometimes Caribou.
We encounter people and
once I've encountered people
they'd get way touch here.
Yeah.
Do you have a catch phrase when you hunt
when you hit one? I sh I need
one. Well yeah. Is that it?
Blam blam we eat ham.
That's awesome. That's the perfect
one for pig hunting. Pick one.
I'm actually,
uh,
I'm in the process of brining a ham
right now that I'm going to smoke.
I bought a smarter means soak it in and
it's soaked in salt and brown sugar and
um, it's been soaking in this,
this brine for like five days.
Wow. And I'm going to, I'm going to smoke
it tomorrow. Yeah. That's awesome man.
This new thing I'm into,
that's great dude.
I eat almost exclusively delivery,
so we lead opposite lives.
Totally opposite labs. I love delivery.
Don't get me wrong. Deliveries.
Like one of the greatest things ever
that you could sit in your house and
someone could bring you a delicious food.
Yeah.
But yeah, we're at the opposite
spectrums of Eden. I am.
Natalie is a middleman,
but there's somebody,
there's a lot of the steps with somebody
bringing it to me, to your house,
my house to the restaurant using an app
to do what I'm using seamless web to do
it and that's going to the restaurant.
The restaurant's getting
the food from somewhere.
Then this making the food and bringing
it to me through and you're actually
going and shooting pigs in the face.
You don't want to shoot him
in the face where you do,
but you don't want to mess miss them.
You know,
if you could shoot him in the head, that'd
be ideal. Yeah. The phases. The head.
Yeah, you're right. What you
mean side of the head? No,
you really want to go for the heart
and the lungs. You go for the body.
That's how you,
uh,
that's how you usually stop them because
you can miss the hat and graze their
nose, blow their face off.
That happens sometimes. Yeah.
Like deer get their face blown off.
Someone tries for a headshot and they
mess and then the animal is still running
around with half a face. Well,
I was just trying to be funny.
Okay.
Me Too. I just failed my part. Failed.
Do you think you could ever do it?
You ever thought about going hunting?
Oh, no, I don't. I'm not a
patient person. I'm very, uh,
I need stuff to happen right away.
Right. So, yeah, I don't, I don't know.
I actually, only time I've ever, I was
in Mississippi when I was a kid. Uh,
my aunt stayed in the country and
missing like I sold the business.
It was a small towns. It's
very conscious. So they,
they were wild hogs around and I was,
I had a shotgun and I was able to,
to shoot one shot off at a, at a pig
that I missed. So that was my only,
that's my only experience with a hunting.
I fished once and caught a fish and
now it was pretty cool. But yeah,
I maybe I could do it.
It will be a different
experience just to be in that,
just that type of life. And
just knowing that, you know,
it's people that do that a lot.
Just seeing that, that type of work.
Like I, uh, for my pilot
for comedy central,
I worked on a goat farm actually
where they milk the goats.
Uh, they, you know, they, they sell
goat milk and everything there. And uh,
they got the Billy goats and
then it was a, it was real.
It was really different just
being in that, in that, uh,
in that environment where
this is these people,
this is what they do for a living.
And they just live off goats state,
you know? Yeah. They milked
goats, they got goat cheese,
they got goat lip balm and this
crazy thing, you know. So that was,
that was real cool. So I am interested
in our world. I don't know if I could,
I could probably visited
your urbanized. Yeah,
I'm urbanized to the core. I think maybe.
Oh, you know, maybe we'll get, I would,
you know, try some different stuff and,
and do it for an extended amount of time.
But right now I'm pretty
comfortable. Yeah, no, look,
the cities are definitely
awesome invention. Yeah.
What a great idea to cut all that
nonsense out. Yeah. But the thing,
the thing I found about is that they're
nonsense or the hunting and fishing too.
They're fun. Yeah. They're fun on some
weird visceral level. It's funny. Yeah.
You fairly, yeah. It feels,
it feels good to go through that where
you kill the animal you do to mediate it
and, and you, you make
it. Yeah. You did it out.
It has a feel. Yeah. Real fulfilling.
And, and you know, that's, I mean,
that's what we used to do as,
as humans.
So you think you'd be interested
in going hunting on a TV show?
Would you be interested in doing it?
Probably.
Great idea for a show. I think that's
the next show. I mean like Steve Rinella,
this guy that, uh, from the host of media,
and I've been trying to think of a show.
I think the show is
taking comedians hunting.
I think that's, look, that's something
that, it's a very controversial thing too.
I mean I don't find it con I
think if you a immediately,
you can't really find it if
you're media controversy,
but you saw about vegetarian
vegetarians have an issue
with it but really dummies.
It's very controversial with dummies, you
know dummies love to knee jerk on that.
Like, oh you want to shoot an
animal? Is that what you want to do?
You I had to kill animals.
You a bad ass. Bad Ass.
Why don't you need to use a knife?
Like they'll say something.
Why don't use your bare hands?
Yeah. Cause you'd fucking lose.
Oh Bitch. What team are you on? Is People
that Feifei it just did in that sense.
You know, it's funny with Pete,
like not a vegetarian debate,
but my girlfriend is vegetarian but uh,
and kosher. But each fish. Huh? But,
and I try to say that's not true.
Vegetarian eat salmon and then
only certain types of fish though.
Only child fully kosher fish.
Kosher fish. Oh, she's crazy.
You got to get away from her. No, she's,
she's good. That's Voodoo. Oh sure.
You food. It's food. I tried
to say like that's old rules.
It's so dumb.
They update it.
Well you know they use that as
like it's certain slaughterhouses,
they have to have a rabbi come and they
see use a knife and the slaughterhouse W
W we filmed fear factor
in a slaughter house.
And that was the first
time in my life that I,
I recognized very clearly
that places contain memories.
They contain something, some feeling of
some shit that went down there. Yeah.
Cause the moment I walked into that
slaughterhouse like the moment,
like as you get closer to
it for you park your car,
you get out of your car and start
walking towards the door. You feel heavy,
you feel it. You could feel it.
You feel weird shit in that place.
She walking around. It might be
psychological, but it might also be,
that place is still buzzing with a million
fucking slaughtered cows freak outs.
Cause it feels like it.
It feels like a where if
you came around that spot,
if you were like in the old school game
of Thrones days and you came over a hill
and you might stop, why do it? Why
does this place feel fucking shitty?
What does going, what's what
happened here? What Joe. Dot.
Phil and Co also going a bit, man,
I'm about to make strange as eat bugs.
There was no eating bugs. It was a
simple task. Then it's dunked her head,
her blood and pull out cow
hearts with their teeth.
What you felt the vibe of that place mom?
Probably full of Shit.
I know I was high as fuck,
so I might've just been tricking
myself into thinking it.
A lot of people get mad sometimes
and when I say, you know,
you feel good and it
doesn't make any sense,
it shit doesn't even make
sense to me. Alright. Relax.
People get upset about pay news.
It's easy to yeah, to kind of people.
You got to take yourself out of yourself
sometimes I remember like, Oh yeah,
that's just the person was saying stuff
like you also gotta be able to poke
holes in your own theory. You have to
like right there, like I'm telling you,
I felt this weird, crazy thing,
but the reality is I was highly,
highly lit up on marijuana. I mean, I
was lit up, used to shoot that show.
How I would do every episode
high as fuck so high.
Sometimes I forget how to talk right?
I can never,
I mean the only way I could do it and
enjoy it because it was so preposterous.
After like eight or nine episodes,
I was like wow, this is the most,
and I was like, God damn it. This show
is going to, it's going to stay on TV.
You know? On one hand I definitely
wanted to stay on TV. So it was great.
Great job. A lot of Nice people I worked
with, the money was great, NBC was great,
but on the other hand I'm like, oh
my God, how can I keep doing this?
I don't know if I can keep doing this.
So it was like a a beautiful job but a
job but a job that I could do high rises.
Then it became fun once
I could do it. Hi. Yes,
funny cause I never smoked weed before.
TV appearances,
anything on TV, but people think
I'm high on TV all the time.
Well if you got tested you would be high.
I think the, what you're talking about,
it's like intoxicated or affected.
There's two different things,
you know what I'm saying? No, I'm
always affected by, we'd always,
they basically medicated by weed,
but I'm not always high. Right.
But I'm affected you mean because you
might have smelled a couple of days ago,
something like that.
Even a day ago,
two days ago went out because it
was a period where I really did,
was smoke weed for a few years. And even
then people say, are you high on stage?
Are you high right now?
You must be [inaudible] have a stoner
style comedy in a lot of ways. Well, I,
I mean it's, it's uh, it's, it sounds
like a negative, but it's a positive.
You're a thinking comedian. You, you're a
really funny writer. Like you take like,
like really hilarious,
absurd turns in your comedy
and it's fun to listen to.
So like when you hear that you
go, oh, this guy's high as fuck,
he's coming up the shot because I
get annoyed because I'm like, if you,
if I was hiding,
do you know how bad this will be
if I was having what's up with all
these lights? Who's that? What are
you looking at me?
Why is he staring at me?
Why is it going with the
cameras staring at me
or you'd get used to it and
be like everything else.
The first time I ever got high on stage
I it was like skiing downhill when you
don't know how to stop. Yeah, it works.
Yeah. I mean I made it to the bottom.
I didn't crash.
It was like one of my best sets ever,
but I didn't do it again for
like 10 years. I was terrified.
I was terrified. I just got high with
some friends and never quite sobered up.
And then all my shit,
I gotta go do comedy and I went
on stage just accidentally. Hi.
It was great,
but I was terrified.
Done it slightly high recently.
I can, but I can't be blitz.
I can't be blazed if I'm blazed.
Don't to blaze. I just got to leave.
But this is a public place with a bunch
of people. If I'm to blame. All right,
see y'all later. I'm going home
to my safe place. It's definitely
times when you can fuck up. You just
get, I want his, uh, there was a, um,
a professional jujitsu tournament
that I went to and met.
A friend of mine was competing in and
we went to watch him and support him.
And um,
after the,
the Jujitsu tournament who went
backstage and, um, we were, uh,
we were all on these pot edibles that
this friend had given us and they were
pills. And my friend said to
only take one, don't take two.
I listened to him. I took one. My friend
Eddie took to Eddie Bravo, took two.
And I was talking to this dude and I
was just way too high to be talking to
anybody.
And the dude that I was talking to,
it's just a straight killer
and he's a weird killer.
He's a guy who had a reputation when he
got in a street fight and actually kill
the guy with a triangle. They had to
revive the guy. He held onto the triangle,
the kind of an altercation on side of
a highway and he got out. I think he,
his friend fought the guy first and then
he fought the guy. I don't know that.
Oh, there's one of those regular
fight with a guy was a regular,
why president was trying to square up
like a regular person and any other
friends or like
fight for living. Exactly. Yeah.
I don't want to say the dude's name
because he wound up actually going to jail
for rape. Um, he, he raped
some chick allegedly. I mean,
I don't know what happened, but he got
arrested for olives now. Alia fans. Well,
I mean, I don't, I don't know what
happened. I don't know that the guy,
he actually had to like skip town. He, uh,
he took off and then they caught
him because he was doing Jujitsu,
couldn't stop doing Jujitsu.
He loved you Jitsu so much that he was,
he went to a gym and he was strangling
motherfuckers and the people couldn't
believe how good he was.
And there's a certain level where like
when you get to like a brown belt level
or black belt level, if
it's something some guy can
manhandle you, you like, Whoa,
who is this guy?
Like this is,
this is something crazy like w have you
competed before? Like ha who are like,
why are you so good?
This guy was just that good.
He was just strangling all these people.
So the rose a bunch of suspicion.
So they checked out his name and they're
like, wow, that's a dude wanted for rate.
So I'm there super high as
fuck before the rape charge,
super high as fuck talking to
this guy. And I'm like, man,
something is wrong with this motherfucker.
I'm like picking up a vibration,
a vibration in his soul. He's willing to
go to dark places if you fuck with him,
like this is the wrong dude to fuck with.
And then a couple months later he's
running from the police doing Jujitsu.
And then as a gnome deplore.
That's crazy. Late season.
Love it so much. I can, I'll do it.
It's like once you get really good at it,
it becomes like a video game.
But like imagine if you could play a
video game in real life where you actually
get to do all the killing and the other
guys really don't even have a good shot
of killing you like the
other. You go ahead and try.
I tried to choke me, you know,
that's how good this guy was.
This guy was so,
he was world class so he would just,
he couldn't resist.
He wanted to go there and just
strangle a bunch of men. You know,
I don't know what it was.
I mean,
somebody might have fucked with him when
he was young and he never forgot it and
he, you know, that's, that happens a lot
of guys, they have like childhood abuse.
Somebody kicks their ass when they're
a kid and they just become this fucking
savage because of that develop
that defensive mechanism. You know,
I enjoy fighting,
but I,
when I watch it like fight and
comes off me enjoy watching it,
I ends up watching it. Yeah. Yeah. I
enjoy watching fight and a in my mailbox,
but just cause it's fascinating.
Like Yo,
these dudes attack each other for living.
That's all they do
is hard way to make it too. It
was like, I'm going to put like,
that's crazy. Know this is my
dream, this is what I want to do.
I want to fight people and I'm willing
to take the chance that I might get
knocked out in front of thousands of
people and millions watching it. Oh.
I don't often recommend people
get high before sporting events,
but if there's a sporting event,
you should definitely get high at least
once and do their live. It's a UFC. Yeah.
Oh yeah. I might, my friends
do it all the time. You know?
Especially in places like
California where it's legal,
they're not really interested
in breaking any laws. Right.
Colorado where it's legal,
Washington state where it's
legal in Washington state.
Last time we went up there. You could
smell weed all throughout the place.
Really walked out. Stuck in the,
in the state at Vancouver too.
You go up to valley, you go. Why?
We had this is a UFC in Vancouver.
The whole place smells like weed. People
just light up. They just keep it low.
Light up right in the stands. Fuck
it. Yeah, man. Just to, I mean,
watching price probably is watching
somebody get knocked out high.
It would be crazy to me.
Live choked out lives crazy,
but it's also watching hub.
Goddamn could they are,
you know when you're super tuned
in for people who don't get high,
the idea behind it is like,
well yeah,
if there's something you
should get drunk and go do,
let's go get drunk and watched
the super bowl. You know?
That's stupid thing to say,
but what I'm saying,
get high and watch mixed martial arts.
You don't even have to watch UFC.
Watched some kickboxing.
When you watch think anything like high
level athletics were two dudes have a
lot at stake, which is what it is.
You're so tuned in to what they're doing.
You're so he, the whole
thing, it's like electrifying.
Right before I used to work for the UFC,
I never, I never do the UFC high ever.
But before I used to work for the UFC,
I used to love to get barbecue and
watched the fights. It was awesome.
So the whole thing,
it's such a such a wild experience,
like primal experience, you
know when your baked, he just
tune into it.
Yes.
Is to man,
I couldn't imagine getting,
just will have seen some of the highlights
of fights where it's just crazy.
Like a guy's getting his ass whooped and
all of a sudden he's whooping up like,
but getting destroyed.
Like the guy got a couple of
punches in like this dude is bloody,
he was just getting destroyed.
Like oh he's about to lose.
And then all of a sudden he has this dude
in a rear naked choke or something and
the dude is tapping out
like how did that happen?
How was he able to take
15 punches to the face?
It happens all the time.
You still win the fight.
There's certain dudes if you
could just take it. Yeah.
That's one of the things
that you learn when you watch
him. My man. Yeah. All that.
All men are created equal bullshit.
Yeah. That's how dirty, stinky lie.
That will fuck you over if you believe
that all men are not created equal. No,
not even a little bit. There's some dudes
they can do shit. You can do that, right?
You can't move like Anderson Silva period.
Right.
If you're some dude who thinks it all men
are created equal and you get in there
with Anderson Silva,
that fucking guy moves like he moves
like he's in another dimension.
Most guys can't handle that. Okay, well I
that x's you exercise your
body, your legs, back,
arms, right? ABS, chest.
You could work that,
but how do you make your face job?
It's a lot of it's genetics.
It's genetically. How could you just
take funds is in the face? Well,
I can't pass out. I can't. I
mean I can, I can, you know,
I've been hit in the face many times,
but I know I don't like it and I know
I'm not the best at it. I don't like it.
Maybe there's a few people that
do like it, but I don't like it.
There's some dudes who forget fired up by,
but there's some guys that take
a shot way better. You know,
I don't have an extraordinary ability
to take a shot, but I don't have a,
I don't have a weak chin either. Some
guys it's really weird. Like, um,
it could be past trauma.
It could be that they've been
hitting the head too many times,
but some guys just can't take a shot at
all. They're just, it's weird. They just,
they get hit like half decent
and there they get wobbly.
Whereas like some dude's like Pacific
islanders, like Samoans. Yeah.
God Damn.
Those dudes are known for and be able
to take a shot like David [inaudible].
You ever see David to a fight?
No. He's a heavyweight boxer. Uh,
fought like he had like crazy potential.
He lost a Lennox Lewis when
Lennox Lewis was on the top there,
but David [inaudible]
was crow Russian people.
He knocked out John Ruiz pull
up David to a versus John Ruiz.
This was a,
when they were both contenders
before Ruiz won the and David
to a knocked him out one
brown Nate David too.
It was terrifying because he get hit
like a train and his head was like fire
hydrants sized and he could just bang
you just take them in the face. There is,
which is scary, right? Oh yeah.
And you see their Olympic bronze
medalist in 92 I mean he was a serious,
serious athlete, so it wasn't just
that he could take a great punch.
He was also an elite boxer.
I mean David [inaudible] in his prime,
he's one of the guys that gets
looked past like on any given night,
David [inaudible] might've been
able to beat everyone in the world.
It just putting together those nights over
and over and over again. Look at this.
Boom, Ruiz is hurt. Look
at this motherfucker.
Come on son. How good was
David [inaudible]? Terrifying.
That's,
that's the mall.
That's most embarrassing when you
have a you as an outside of the ring.
That's Worsten.
He says sub more demoralizing about that.
And your wife has their shit.
Yeah, dude, he got fucked
up. Kids are crying.
The world was deemed denied.
David to a versus Mike Tyson.
It's a denial, like the world lost
something because those two never fought.
You know,
I mean God Damn David Tool was good.
Lennox fought Tyson, but
Tyson was already, you know,
look at this, he's out cold.
But Tyson was a already,
you know,
pass his prime and he had chemical
problems and he was doing coke apparently.
So do you think when like say like David
[inaudible] was probably heavily favor
for that fight,
right?
I don't know who was favorite cause John
Ruisa stud man. John Ruiz is a, you know,
he,
he won the title.
He beat some really high level guys like
John John Ruiz, a real good boxer. Okay.
But say a two just caught him.
But I just mean like say a fight like
with too is it gets somebody to is highly
favored.
But this other guy has his team there.
You know that everybody's hyped.
Like you gotta get up.
But do you think there's people in that
say like, man, he's about to get his ass.
Of course you got to get
rid of those people, man.
I see people on your team that will say
that to you, man. Don't fight that dude.
You know what the fuck man.
You can't say that shit.
You do need to hear that though. You
know, you do need to hear that. You Go,
Oh want that.
You need it.
I mean, but it also is a,
it's a job to where like,
well he probably a little whip
my ass, but mortgages, dude,
this certain dudes like when d
like here's a perfect example,
when Vinny Pazienza
fought Roy Jones jr he,
someone should have pulled Vinea
side and went and listened. Dude,
don't fight this guy. Yeah. Like this
is not the guy for you. Not right now.
Did he beat the first round of something?
He was the only guy I ever,
Vinny Pazienza was to never score
a single punch and around ever.
Roy Jones hit him at will and he literally
couldn't hit Roy Jones was when Roy
Jones was in the matrix. It was
dancing and [inaudible] Jones. Yeah.
Jones went through like a series
of of of years where everybody was
like, oh, he's got no, he's got no
competition. You know, it's too bad.
There's not another really good fighter.
It's not,
there's not a really good fighter.
He says he's so fucking good that he
makes everybody else look like they don't
belong in there with him. Guys who in
any other era were bad motherfuckers,
right. Do this is Roy Jones when he was,
he was the best ever, in my opinion.
He was the most impressive fighter ever
for a period of a few answers to his rap
song. Yeah. Well, must've
forgot this is when he,
when he finished, patsy ends at the end
of the fight. God Damn, he was good.
Or is this the first round?
This is the first round.
This was when Roy Jones Jr was,
he was literally perfect.
He had reflexes that no one can fuck
with completely unorthodox style.
Very rarely used a jab use leaping left
hooks as much as you used the jab and
was just so fucking fast. Man. He just
couldn't catch up with that rhythm.
His rhythm was so fast.
It was just,
it would fuck with guys because they'd
get in there and you've got a certain
expectation of how long it's gonna take.
Four guy hits you.
So like if you're here and he's here,
maybe something could come here.
Maybe what we'll throw at John's house,
you'd be like,
Oh shit,
I can't get away from those.
I don't even know when those
are coming. Yeah. I saw a,
I went to Mayweather Canelo ah,
that was a masterful work. Yeah.
And I asked her full,
I never see Mayweather alive and
I knew it was great obviously,
but when you see him live,
you see how fast he is.
Like so much than Canelo's only 21 or,
and may psalm 37 and he was way faster
than him and just dodged everything that
he anticipated. Every movie. It was crazy
to see how fast and just scale what he,
what, you know what it also is. It's
not just fast. He's really good.
He's really good technically.
And by that,
what I mean is that for folks
who just watch like a guy box,
you're seeing a guy move around,
you go,
oh well this guy is trying to hit this
guy and that guy was trying to avoid it.
But there's a language going on.
Just like when you're
speaking in a conversation,
just like with two people are speaking.
Like if you and I were talking and
we're having a good conversation,
it's because I'm recognizing what you're
saying and you're recognize what I'm
saying and we're combining our thoughts
together with laughing and having some
fun.
This is like a flow to it,
but you could have a conversation with
some other person who just gets real
aggressive with you and Tim,
you don't want to talk because you're
intimidated or you start stuttering in
your words because you know this,
you think this guy's gonna
bark at you or you're,
you're worried that you're saying
something wrong because they're being very
judgmental towards you.
And so then the conversation takes
on a completely different flow. Well,
that's what fighting is. Fighting is
like that. It's like there's like,
there's like movements and there's
movements to get you to react and then
there's recognizing your movements and
your patterns and playing off of them
erupting those patterns.
Just like when someone's argumentative
and they interrupt you in mid
conversation to refute the first couple
things you said and it throws you off.
You can't keep failing.
You keep your try to finish your thought,
but it's not the same thought as it was
because they got blocked too. Right.
That's like a guy gets hit,
but he still tries to punch the gun.
When the guys out of range knowing the
guys had a range just to let them know
it's really essentially the same
thing. So what may, whether is in his,
his mastery is like a masterful
physical conversationalist.
He knows how to control the
action. That's, that's a
weird thing. It's like, oh,
there's a Voodoo to that
when a guy's had his best,
like a Roy Jones in his prime or a May,
whether right now there's a Voodoo
to the way they move. Right.
You think Mayweather. He'll, he won't,
he won't get beat before
he retires or you think
I worry about him beating himself. Yeah.
I worry about him doing something crazy.
Like you heard what happened with
those guys that were working for him.
Some jewelry went up missing.
He had these guys allegedly,
allegedly they got the shit beat
out of him. But now it's all,
it's all seems to go away.
No charges have been filed,
which is the right way to handle it.
Just sorry.
Apparently the guys weren't the
people who stole the jewelry.
But look what I'm hearing.
You know, 18th hand stories.
I don't know what the
fuck really happened,
but let's pretend nothing ever happened.
It was a total misunderstanding.
What I worry is it something like that
would happen and then he would wind up
going to jail again. You
know? I mean, I just think the
guy, if you're a boxing fan,
I think he's one of the best
ever. I think he's, it's like a,
as far as like an athlete, I think
Mayweather's like a national hero. Yeah.
I mean not a national here like
a national treasure. You know,
it's like you should really pay attention
to this cause this is very rare that a
guy has this much better than everybody
around him. Nobody could touch him.
He's standing in front of a murderous
puncher and Canelo Alvarez and Canelo's
all frustrated and flustered
and he's can't hit the dude.
That's funny. I always hit people say,
hey, whether there's arrogant, Yay Erika.
He punches people into Facebook living
and he's never lost it and he's not
punching regular people would if he's
punching other people in the face.
That also punch people
in the face for yes,
he's arrogant and he'd done it over and
over and over for millions of dollars
and that's all he does.
You can't be not arrogant and be
that good. You can not display it.
Yeah, you could do better at hiding
it, but that's tough. But with him,
the thing is about hiding. It wouldn't
be necessarily beneficial financially.
Yeah.
If it's better to create that persona.
If people want to see him lose 20 30%
of the people that buy a main where the
ticket or trying to see him lose,
I will say more 50.
It depends on who he's fighting.
Yeah. Well yeah, that's true.
But I mean like no
matter who he's fighting
Mexican flags in that in uh,
in the stadium when I was there.
That's true. But I think
there's some people that pay
to see him lose to anybody,
whether it's Canelo Alvarez was
Filipino menu, no matter what anybody,
they just want
to see this motherfucker Lewis,
Ricky Hatton
there were so disappointed to the English
people thought this is the guy fucking
come over here at beat Floyd Mayweather
couldn't even touch that dude. It hasn't,
he had a downward spiral since.
Hadn't, hadn't did. Yeah.
He got knocked out by a pack gal really
bad after Mayweather. Knocked him out.
Mayweather knocked him out.
But Mayweather, like he hit
him with a left hook. He,
but he out.
It's just outboxed him master fleet and
then caught him on the chin or wobbled
him and then finished him off.
But Manny Pacquiao slept him.
He caught him after that fight.
So it was too bad knockouts and then,
you know,
he took a lot of time off and
started hitting the white.
Yeah. Ricky Hatton need to get
in the supplements of business.
Well he came back, he got a, he had a
coke problem for a while. It got crazy,
you know, did a lot of partying, you know,
got depressed and then got right back
into it and got back in shape and had a
fight and lost the fight.
But a,
I think he decided after that he just
couldn't perform at the same level anymore
and he was going to retire.
But you've got to realize for him,
if you're listening, Ricky,
you can't expect you bought it.
It bounce completely back with one
fight after he did coke for five years.
You know, I mean, I dunno what
they told you coke does, but uh,
you need to give yourself
some recovery time.
You know coke set in this,
I know people did coke in the 70s they
have like serious neural muscular problem.
So Shit.
Yeah,
the people like a lot of old people that
did a lot of coke like way back when
they developed like all sorts of
like weird nervous problems. Weird.
We're weird issues with
controlling their bodies.
You know like there's a direct connection
that a lot of people have with a,
with Richard Pryor went through when he
was older with all the coke that he did
when he was younger.
Yeah.
So don't do that much coke,
coke and moderation. Everybody in
light moderation if you have to,
if that don't do it at all.
I also think it's real. It's a real
problem with coke being illegals.
You don't know what the fuck you're
getting a coke mixed with some speed.
Yeah.
Well you know the government can't
get go that far in legalized coke.
Do you? Don't think so. Do you?
What about decriminalizing it?
Do you think that that's possible?
That's possible.
I still make it.
It's still a B.
I think it will still have
the same problems. Right?
But what did it mean? How much? How
much worse? I've never done coke.
How much worse is coke than alcohol? When
you see someone who's really fucked up,
drunk,
violent,
I've seen people that are due to become
totally rapey when they get drunk,
just grabbing girls outside of clubs
can't bitch. I've seen people get crazy.
Come on girl. What the
fuck you too. Good for me.
It's a tough comparison just
because of how people take them.
You know what I mean? Like people,
you might have eight shots of lick,
but for the most part people,
I mean there's some people definitely
that's on the extreme side,
but you're not going
to keep on it and coke,
uh, that is a problem. Right?
And so once you feed that monkey,
you want to keep feeding it. Yeah. That's
the difference, right? Cause you guys,
you can also get kinda crazy apparently
when you've been doing coke all night.
Like you don't know what the
fuck you're doing, you know,
energy and you just feel
smarter than you are
how you are when you're drunk too. Right?
You're drunk, you're half retarded,
you think you're fine, but you
don't slur as much coke. Right.
But you talk more talk more. Yeah. That
is one of the most brutal things ever.
Talking to a drunk person when we Schober
or talking to a coke head when you saw,
which would you rather,
uh,
however out the top pride sort of cocaine
cause they probably at least have some
ideas and shit and he,
even if they had,
even if the ideas aren't that great,
I would be in my sober man so I'm
be able to tweak it to my advantage.
Da. Yeah. Oh, okay.
Counter. And it's like actually kind
of got the conversation a little bit.
Yeah. You know, Mike Young, do you know
Mike Young comedian? I know that is, yeah.
He had a great joke about a coke heads
that they always want to start businesses
with it.
Yeah,
true man. People will come up to
you with like grand plans. Yeah.
Do, I mean I, uh, I have add,
but I don't have an Adderall prescription,
but I get it.
Sometimes I get out of raw sometimes
and when I take an Adderall at the
beginning of the day, man, I
just crushed life. Dude. I book,
I book all my flights for the next
month and a half. I'll get shit done,
shit done. I write, I make lists, I
handle stuff in my apartment and just,
uh, just handle the stuff on
Adderall. I'm legit add, I think.
Do you think that, um, okay, when
when someone says I'm a legit add.
Yeah. I believe you, and I'm
not questioning you but isn't,
you're talking about the effects of a
stimulant though, right? I mean, when,
when people do stimulants, that's
what happens. Yeah. But I think,
cause I don't get to the point
where I'm like, Eh, like,
cause some people take Adderall and
they'll go, ah, there'll be really hype.
Well for me you wouldn't be able to
tell that I'm right, then I'm pumped up.
You know what I mean? Like
it, you have much more energy,
but I have much more energy and
just focus and I just handle stuff.
Whereas I normally, you know, I'll get
on the internet and just, I go, you know,
on my computer with plants and just in
a dicking around on Twitter, looking at,
I'll get caught up in a youtube
wormhole, you know what I mean? Wormhole,
I get nose. Oh Man. It's a waste.
Have you ever tried my [inaudible]?
Do you know what that is or what that is?
Is that your other supplement? No, no, no.
That's a pharmaceutical. Yeah.
Yeah. It's um, it's a smart drug.
There's new vigil and
Provigil Provigil was, uh,
the original one I think in new
visuals, the newer version. Anyway,
I've only taught, tried new
vaginal, but apparently this is,
their effects are very similar.
It's this weird drug, right?
And what it does is it just gives you
energy, like when you're exhausted,
like say if you, um, like last night I
got decent amount of sleep, six hours.
I have kids. So six hours are pretty
good, you know, so I feel pretty good.
But if you get three hours
and you're like, fuck,
I gotta do a bunch of Shit today,
you can take one of these new deals.
And it's not like coffee.
It's not like that weird when I,
when I'm like really
tired but I drink coffee,
I get that buzzy but dull thing like
I'm kinda stupid but I'm moving around
normal. This is not like that.
This is like, it alleviates
the sleepiness right on.
It's all gone, all gone and now
you have a energy and it's amazing.
Yeah. Yeah. Neat. Stuff like
that. Cause I got, you know,
stand up and working on show
the press stuff. Energy neat.
Especially for press site. If I had to
do more than impress on the road, man,
just to God, just to get through those
interviews and just to be, be on point.
I had to have something.
What folks don't realize
and we, you know, you fucking wait,
you gotta be there at like six in the
morning and you work til like 10 o'clock
at night on a most, you know,
most nights. Even later. Yeah.
It's not even, it's just a
thing. It's just to be on point.
Isn't that an [inaudible] I try not to
complain about just because it's part of
is part of the job and I'd rather do
it then work construction any day.
But sometimes mentally it's tough to
do a morning interview. But if I have,
if I have, you know, take Adderall
before then I'm snappy, I got jumped,
I got anecdotes and then I can kind of,
I know sometimes now
I was learning how to,
you got to take an interview
over sometimes or want to
not go on a rant but you
have to not let them, you know,
just cause they can get into that,
cutting off your jokes and hey, a funny
man handlebars just cutting you off.
So just learning how to,
how to do that and just having the
energy and focus to be able to is,
it's real helpful. Yeah. The morning
radio thing, if like they're good,
it's great. It's real fun. It's pro
is supported and set you up and,
but then sometimes they just like, so
what's funny in the world right now? Like
inner bunny the other day,
the guy who asked me that exact question,
what's making you laugh
right now? Ah, to Hannah,
but what are you talking about on stage?
Oh Man, I hate when they do. Yeah.
Somebody asked me that before a show.
I was doing it.
And what are you going to talk about?
Man?
Just came up like what are we talking
about today? Like you now, you
dudes that would go,
well, here's my new piece.
It's all about how man is constricted by
a first his mom and his wife and a then
ultimately his lawyer.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I
guess the thing is just,
I try to remember that people aren't
coming from a shitty place normally.
They just don't know how to communicate
to me in a way that won't make me feel
cynical and hate them. You know what
I mean? So I gotta keep that in mind.
But in the moment, like what the fuck
are you just asking me? What's funny?
In a world right now
for someone who's not a comic.
They wouldn't understand
how awkward that would be.
Like what you like when you can go on a
radio show and they just let you talk.
Right. Just go hang out.
Let's just hang out, hang out,
talk about stuff back and forth
from each other. Yeah. Yeah.
It's not a lot of them. They can
do that though. Cause that problem.
Do you ever do those radio tours?
We have to call like 10 different people
and then you realize like eight of them
have the same voice,
like almost exactly.
What does this, the radio
voice, I don't know what, when
it was tested, when it was,
it was, it was, it was a study that
people, that people like to listen to.
This right here, we live
here in Nashville. We got
Hannibal Buress in the studio.
We alive here in Cincinnati.
We got handled. There's a
couple versions of that.
This is a couple of versions
of that was just, you know,
and it was the sports guy as well.
Gus Johnson here for showtime.
There's the news guy.
It's just the same as um,
rappers though too. Like rappers,
rap voice. You'd talk to a
rapper, they might sound like me,
but then when in their wrapped it like,
you know what it is, it's a persona.
It's just a persona that you know,
works for that situation
though. I liked the, the Gus Johnson
type voice. Like if a guy's, uh,
like when I say that about Gus Johnson,
I'm not putting them down.
Like I like that professional.
Here we are Madison Square Garden.
I don't want a guy who's like,
Hey, I'm like me. Like I,
when I do the UFC there's a reason why
I'm the color guy and I'm not the play by
play guy. I don't do the big,
here we are Joe FC one 52.
Like those guys are important.
I like that.
I mean it is [inaudible] tree.
Its pageantry isn't a reason why
Michael buffer works well. Yeah.
That's even more so because
he's a announcer said let's
get ready to rumble this
pageantry dog pageants. Yeah. I'm
not putting it down but it is weird.
Radio is weird and radio cause you don't
have to talk like radio's different
cause it's supposed to be your
personality. You know what I mean?
Like sports as a sports guy,
the news is the news,
but radios was to be your vibe.
But then you sound like the
dude in Saint Louis also.
You sound like the dude
who's all over the place.
Every guy you know another
place where that exists. What
was that? Strip club Djs.
Uh,
yeah,
I've been trying to analyze this for many
years and I think with Strip club Djs
it's like no one wants to hear a dude
talking while girls are dancing naked.
You do not want to hear that guy.
So he's got to make it like a song,
like all ride coming to this stage.
It's amber,
remember everybody $40 comic cons.
She's like,
there's an entertainment aspect to that.
What he's doing.
It's like he's almost
like he's singing a song.
What have you been to a black strip
club in Atlanta though? No, CJ's no.
Those djs out of most amazing Dj's.
Focally f really because
they drive the tipping,
you know what I mean? They crack
jokes. I relapsed when I was in.
It's so funny like man, you need to
pay the puzzle. They are bugs in here.
Y'all ain't spending money.
They'll drop the track.
They'd come and cut the track by
not spend some mother fucking money.
Look what she's doing up there.
She's up there like the
Atlanta Dj's is strip club.
Amazing.
They
probably just other black that black
strip clubs like the DJ drives that Shit
and is the driving force
and as an entertainer in
addition to add he adds to it.
See now I'm weighing the potential
dangers of going to a black strip club in
Atlanta with the entertainment aspect
of how amazing. That must dangerous man.
Isn't that that guy like me?
No there's no,
I'm sure.
I'm sure I need to go if I go with you.
If I go with you I could slide right in.
I'm not even that blood. Then I play.
Yeah the black in a black strip club.
The djs,
the right and there famous ones is fate.
I don't know the names though.
Cause I have a bit, but you go to
somewhere a magic city or magic city,
a few other ones in
Atlanta. Uh, the Dj is, is,
is important and makes the strippers
more money and the Strip was probably end
up tipping out the DJ.
Right?
I'm sure. Yeah. They have like
an arrangement, right? Yeah.
My friend Eddie used to work at a strip
club. I used to go and visit him at work,
watch it. Who's Dj? So I got
to, I got to see the craft.
I got to see how everybody does it.
It's interesting the relationship
they all have, it becomes just like,
I mean you might as well
be working in a restaurant.
Everybody develops the same
sort of widespread. Exactly.
People get naked and that's, it's weird
cause it's porn. Porn is like that too.
Like those people get used to each
other and it becomes just like any other
normal.
So you later good Jason on you
see?
So I think it's probably funny when it's
just somebody who you fucked like two
years ago.
Oh good to see you again.
They, I think they have definitely a
more relaxed attitude about it. Yeah.
You know, if you run into somebody that
used to fuck out of nowhere, you're like,
hey, look at me. I see you naked.
All right. You take care
of. Don't mind that Mo.
It's weird when you haven't seen someone
at 20 years and then you get to see
like, whoa, this is weird. This
is weird. Hello, Nina Hartley.
I met her. She's very nice lady. She was
doing Kevin Pereira as podcast. Yeah.
I sat there and talked to her for awhile.
She does everything with gloves on, man.
Good. Yeah. She has like
sex sessions with people.
She puts like surgical gloves alone.
Yes, he does corporates. Right. Does she?
I think a lot of them, yeah. A lot
of them to do like corporate gigs.
Corporates in quotes, quotes,
I guess. Sort of. Yeah.
And the way that corporates,
private privates. Yes.
She does a lot of privates.
Yeah. Like, you know. Yeah.
Very few comics do privates.
What would you do if
someone said, hey man, uh,
Burress I want you to come over
and just do comedy. Just for me.
I'm just a big comedy fan,
but I don't like going to comedy
clubs because it's fucking,
I don't like laughing around other people.
So could you just do your act for me and
I'll pay you what you get paid for like
a regular show for a packed house
for a no,
they add the charge to my,
my corporate college
rate. Okay. And I would,
I wouldn't want to do that.
Can I bring somebody with me?
Well now you're worried about your safety.
Don't worry.
The guy's only going to masturbate.
He promised nothing really crazy.
He just wants to watch you just
he's going to keep his pants.
Well keep a towel on.
Nah,
I'm not doing that good cause I don't
need the money that bad cause I got my own
supplements
business
so I'm that, you know, I could do
stuff as I want to do it, you know.
All right. How about if the dude wears
like a space suit? The space suit? Yeah,
there with a space.
How long ago was that fucking full set.
Full outline set
one dude. But one dude,
can I bring an opener
toe to warm up?
He's going to watch your past
specials so I can't even,
I can't even drop him nets.
I got to do a hour new.
Well it feels a fan man.
You he'd already paid due to do a one on
one show. It does bits. You already know
that was a shift from your last
Shaw crowd work. So this is crazy.
Look at this place.
50 gs.
That's my rate for that weird ass shit.
They're thinking about it. Some
fucking tech guy who's was super rich.
I'm going to get animal breasts.
You just to stand up.
Well it will be less weird
if it was him and his buddy.
That would be way less weird.
Two dudes would be.
Isn't it an interesting like
inch instantly becomes less gay?
Yeah.
Cause it's just also laugh at being at
a comedy show with some is about like
looking over at the person that, you
know what I mean? Like doing the elbow.
So just doing stand up for one person.
It is weird as hell.
Did you find it's weird even
to watch it on television?
It, it, well it's a little, the vibe is
so much different, so much different.
It's just a different energy and
just, it is, it is isn't not weird,
but it is where I've had people that
say they saw my stuff online or they saw
stuff on TV, but then they saw me live and
he was like, Oh shit live. It was crazy.
So it is just,
it's hard to translate the true energy
that's in the room and just that,
that type of thing.
Yeah. They don't want tune into
you when they're watching a video.
They're just getting the words and
the performance. They're laughing,
but they're not too in India,
if there's some dudes like
you'll see them on stage.
Like Brian Cowan is a perfect
example. Yeah. Brian Cowen,
like if you watch them in a video,
he's hilarious.
But if you watch him live that
dude like tune you tune into them,
it's infinitely better.
Well. Yeah cause the bits also, you know,
you might see a a minute set out
of somebody's hours, say online,
but then in the,
if somebody our club
say out a theater set,
you didn't get to see how they enter in,
how they command at the room
at the beginning and how,
what they did at the beginning to allow
them to be able to go to a weird place
later where the audience already
has that trust. So it's a,
it's a lot of different elements to live
standup that get lost in the Internet
and TV.
That's a great point. The, the,
the building up like, you know,
like I've ever had friends that were just
starting out and they'll do something
like they have a bit and they'll do
this bit like right away. And I'm like,
you know what man,
the audience should probably get to know
you better before you do that bit there.
Let them gain your trust first and then
do that bit because the opening part of
it,
like you're immediately,
you have to know you're a good person
for that to be funny. You got to know.
You're kidding. Right.
Otherwise it's just gross.
Yeah. Like I got a joke about how,
uh, the movie I spit on your grave.
Have you seen that? Yeah. It's a
weird movie and I do a bit about it,
but I would never open with that.
That's is coming at least 25,
30 minutes.
Then it's a touchy subject
in that weird.
They have to have trust in you.
Yeah. They have to ask for
us and like you can't, yeah.
You have to establish your
funny for a little bit.
Yeah. And that's really hard, especially
when you're starting out. Yeah.
People don't know you, you know,
once they come to Hannibal Presto,
they know who you are. They're,
they're here to see you. But if you,
if you start now, man, if
you're just a first, you know,
first year guy like,
man,
you got to really get
these people's attention.
Like you've got to figure out a way to
get them to trust you because they're
going to make a judgment call on
you within a couple of minutes.
It's less. Yeah. They'll judge
you. The outfit, a black crowd.
Why you walking up like Ah, it shoes.
So you already lost half the audience.
[inaudible] it looks kind of weird.
Fin that's,
you already got up work hard.
Yeah. Damn, that's hilarious.
Why are black clubs so
much more judgmental?
It's just a, I mean there's just a
level of performance and just, you know,
demand more man
boy and just, you know,
that the best black comics,
it's just been great performance. You
know what I mean? So you talk about, yeah,
just a Red Fox and Richard Pryor
and Bernie like these as well.
Not only, you know, great
joke writers and stuff,
but they performed and they would crush.
And so it's just a higher standard
for performance also in, uh,
black clubs or black, uh, showcase nights.
The host is usually the star of the show
a lot of the time. You know what I mean?
Where on the road in an Improv, a
funny bone, they will see as local.
Sometimes he's good, but
for the most part that, uh,
the host is not going to be that great,
which is not cool because that's
who's setting the tone for the show.
And just that you, the first person in
the audience seeing, you know, donate,
they got babysitters and od
at and they, the, the host,
the first person on stage is eh, where's
the host at? A black line is the,
usually has a local following is great,
crushes does 20th,
30 up top sometimes.
And so it's just a different thing.
So then the next act has to be able to
follow this amazing host with a great
file.
It,
so it ends up with a lot of co comedians
been a lot of black comedians being
real strong performance, uh, early on.
I think that's interesting because,
you know,
Chris Rock said that about his career
that like one time he had a go on after
Martin Lawrence. Yeah. And then he,
he really was a turning point in his
career because he realized that he had
performed to too many white crowds.
Yeah.
And he was like white
crowds made him lazy.
Like he didn't even realize he had gotten
into this sort of like lower energy
sort of mode of performing.
Yeah. Yeah. I was uh, I mean
I wouldn't say it was black.
Crowes it gave me a ship.
I will,
I'm a little bit higher ed is he now
than I was in my first a CD but is that's
just from um, play in, Oh shit.
That's just some playing
bigger venues and learning.
Joseph spilled coffee
on my fucking computer.
A copy of this gives us unbelievable man.
I've done this like four times in the
last month. Shit man. You know what it is,
man. I keep this Coffee Cup right here
and I talk with my fucking hands because I
have peasant roots. Huh? Is that,
is that what that means? It's okay.
The computer is going to be fine. Okay,
cool. Just a minor AppleCare which,
but it was no one don't be like pitch.
This is the third time he came here.
He gets the fuck out of here. Stupid
as a 24 hour apple store in Manhattan.
That's gotta be interesting.
Yeah,
it's very interesting cause I
needed to get a new iPhone, uh,
last week and I went in there faded and
the worst president in the world is a
drunk with a customer service issue.
I was the worst to how drunk were you?
I was drunk enough to,
or I'm worried that
they'll hack into my shit.
Oh, that's hilarious. It was pretty,
I feel bad about it. I was just like,
cause the dude, they weren't helpful.
I have missed my appointment.
I had a 1230 appointment, I popped
in at two. It gave me a new phone.
Okay.
How's the worst? His name was, hey
Suze. And I was like, come on, Jesus.
And we were going back and forth.
He wasn't, he wasn't great to me,
but he also wasn't, I was being a
dick to, you know what I mean? So,
and also I was drunk.
I felt bad about it.
I felt bad about it the next day. God
dammit, I'm an apple store via drug.
They must get drunk people all the time
at apple stores? Probably, I mean, yeah.
Now 24 hour apple, our apple
store, they used to outside. Yeah.
If you getting your iPhone fixed
at four o'clock in the morning,
you gotta be fucked up.
Yeah. Cause you get an
activated iPhone and four o'clock in
the morning. Can they activate it?
Iphone at four o'clock
could I want to do that?
Uh, yeah, it's a 24 hour uh, apple store.
Cause I had to get a new laptop last week.
So at 25 apple store, 24 hour best bus.
So I did my shopping late,
went and got a computer,
went to best buy grout,
Xbox one late at night.
Great Shot. Yeah. Yeah, I heard about
the best part. It's 24 our best box.
That's like near college,
right?
It's a [inaudible] not too far from
Nyu. Yeah. So it's a union square.
That's the one thing that Manhattan has.
It's this 24 hour thing almost.
You know what they don't have
any more though is pool halls.
He used to have a 24 hour pool.
I don't think they have that anymore.
Having gone these to have this
place, Chelsea billiards. It was,
there was a quite a few places,
but Chelsea was the big one that
was open 24 hours a day. Yeah,
go there at four o'clock in the morning
and you have a big pool guy. Yeah.
I love pool a little about what you think
about trick shot. Full stupid. Really?
It's pointless. Yeah. I like tricks up.
Pool is like tying a duck to a stick
and shooting it out of the sky.
Yeah, that's what it's like.
The difference between a,
you get to choose your shots.
That's ridiculous.
The whole idea pool is figuring out the
patterns and moving the ball around,
controlling the cue ball,
making shots and and running out.
Do the table presents you with a problem,
right?
You have to figure out
that problem and get out.
This is some stupid thing that
you practice over and over again,
so I have to do is just poke at the
stick and the ball's going in the right
direction because you set
them up. That's dumb. Oh,
I guess it's good entertainment. TV,
you know what it is. You know what?
And I understand your thought
process behind it, but
yeah, but you know, I don't,
I don't get to see them practice. Yeah.
You see the shot. I just seen him do it.
Let's go. It does look cool. Don't get me
wrong. I seen trick shots. It looked cool,
but I don't, I've been playing pool for
20 years. I don't know how to do one.
I can't do one trick shot. Like I
played pretty decent, but I can't,
I don't know any of them.
I have no desire to learn him either.
They just don't make any sense to
me. It's like, who cares? You said,
you know what people do that.
Like say if a PR professional
came to your pool hall,
it was doing a demonstration. People
like to see trick shots. Yeah.
Like it'd be higher.
I got like Earl Strickland.
Earl Strickland comes to your
pool hall. He's gonna, you know,
he'll do some trick shots for you. I would
act as you, I'll of course, you know,
I'm like, you know, pool celebrities
too. We'll get names. Yeah.
Yeah. I get into shit, man.
Yeah. When I'm, when I'm in
the shit, I get into it. Yeah,
you got, you should get pool kills
man. I guess that'd be cool. No,
I mean young business Joe Blow Joe
Rogan Cuckoos Nah, Nah, that's that.
Probably no pool cues.
You'll only want to buy from a dude
who actually makes the pool cue.
There's a thing about pool cue artisans.
They make pool cues and like when you
buy him from a guy who was like a,
like a Zen Bodi or a task Arella
like take, we'll have these names.
Like they make these exotic pool cues
out of wood and their craftsmanship and
they cut them place in precisely.
And it's a big like art form to it.
Ah, so you wouldn't want
to buy my fucking book.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
Can't buy a pool cue with my name on it,
but stupid. You didn't, you'd be an idiot.
You want to buy a southwest,
you know you want to buy a Jean to,
you want to buy cues that have
a name to him. Okay, cool.
This is like a longstanding art form of,
it's almost like a Samurai sword type
of thing where there's like certain
artists that are preferred
over other artists.
Certain the artisans that have a like a
long history passed down from father to
son. It's very common. Wow. Yeah.
I actually, I mean I'd be
pissed. Why if like, man,
I don't want to be in a pool.
Cubin
I'm passing on this pool cubit.
I don't even like pull that.
Well, if you did like pool
then it would be good,
but if they want it to be a comedian,
I could see your point. Yeah.
Long hours in the shop.
Breathing in fucking saw dust
and glue fumes and shit. Yeah.
Working in a paint booth. One of those
gas masks on. Yeah, that would be,
it's not for Hannibal Burress.
Snapvault isn't.
That for me is not for a lot of people.
It might not be fun at those father son
team. They might not like that shit.
Maybe I would have to talk to
them and just work individually.
I hope I don't get angry white from the
Southwest Pool Cup. I'm sure you would.
I'm sure there'll be pest.
Yeah. Yeah. There's uh,
quite a few people that take
that very seriously. Yeah.
Well are you into anything?
Do you play any games or anything?
Do you do anything on the road? Do you
bowl? I've got a marble collection.
I don't have a marble collection. I
played video games a little bit. I'm a,
but I'm trying to think of
my other stuff that I do.
I'm a pretty pretty bar in dope man.
I'd play video games, do
comedy, go to concerts.
And that's pretty much it.
Yeah.
Keep track of my frequent
flyer miles. Very, uh, heavily
no. How boring stuff. How hardcore
do you get with the video games?
Do you actually bring console with you
on the road? Are you one of those dudes?
No, I can't do that. There's a lot
of dudes and get crazy with that.
Yeah.
Cause it's not because it makes it more,
it makes it more exciting for when I get
back home. Cause that Kinda is how I,
you know, I'm really at home if I'm
sitting at home playing video games,
if I've been gone for 10 days, like
all right relax, I'm home, play a game.
So that's, that's the thing. I, I leave
the game at home. It's a good move.
But I get into it.
I only played two games.
Gta and NBA Two k 14.
That's it.
That's pretty much it.
Cause I'm always gone so I
don't have time to you switching
games. Yeah. I want to get some skills,
learn the game and then enjoy it.
Shoes is learning a new game. I might
try out this titan fall. I got that, uh,
for the Xbox while I
haven't played it yet.
I keep hearing incredible things.
Yeah.
People have like emailed
me if you thinking about
getting back into video games,
this is the video game to get back into
with. I'm like, get the fuck away from me.
Yeah. And that's the thing. So you
don't have time to play, but you got,
so you got a lot of work and I was
thinking about that too when I'm playing
because I can't play for three
or four hours straight limit.
I should I be playing this or
should I be writing a script?
Should I really be playing against this
13 year old like talking shit to him?
I don't talk shit. I might send that.
I might if they talk cause I don't,
I can't have a strain.
I can't,
I don't put on the headset when it's
a strain that can just have a stranger
having that much access
to my brain like that.
I already already do that with Twitter.
I can't have their voice.
Right. Yeah. Could you imagine
if that's the new Twitter,
if people just to be able to anonymously
talk shit to you right to nowhere.
Yeah. Just like a, you can get
your APP mentions on Twitter.
If you could just get
like one after the other,
a bunch of people talking shit
in your hair, your glasses.
We'll smudge. Don't TV.
Good.
She looks stupid.
Well, cost of sneakers are those. Where'd
you get that jacket? That was suck, man.
I delete. You know what, I delete my
Twitter app sometimes just cause I,
I spend too much time on it.
D really?
But then I ended up putting it back
on like two days later. But I do,
but the Times that I'm
trying to have like,
and I'm going to try to two hours a day.
Why?
Just unplugged to awake hours a day
while unplugged. Like
no computer, no phone.
So I either rewrite or workout
or just talk or just chill.
But no looking at the phone, no
email, no texting, none of that.
So that's what I'm trying to do. Just
because I found when my phone was broken,
I had, I didn't have my phone for
a day. It just, it was broken.
I've found that I was, I was a
little bit more productive. I read,
I read a little bit of a book, I wrote
like six jokes or sobbing and I was,
I felt uh,
uh,
way more clearheaded because I
wasn't just checking peoples.
You weren't tethered.
I wasn't tethered.
I wasn't checking Twitter obsessively
and compulsively and yeah.
So that that's what,
that's why new shit.
Yeah. I get tethered to that fucking
phone man. It's weird. It's tough.
It's weird when you're out and you just
have this desire to check your email for
no reason. What the fuck like, like it's
nothing that important in the email.
Cause if it was it'd be a phone call.
Yeah.
Especially when you know you're not
in the middle of doing anything.
It's not like you're like a deal's
about to go down. Alright Hannibal,
stay near the phone. We're
going to call on. You said that
even if it was going down,
isn't that going away?
Is that going away and a dealer's going
to go down but you didn't get back to us
back to us in 20 minutes.
We thought you one of the most hilarious
guys of all time in a future superstar.
But time is as the essence
time is of the essence.
We just called some other dude that we
had on our list of guys whose day to make
and he checks his phone all the time.
It does get like that though when
it's casting, when they get casting,
when it gets down to casting calls,
whether or not you agree to take a show,
like they give you a offer and as a
counter offer they have offers on someone
else and then you know, it
was like a backup offer. Well,
if animal gets crazy with the money,
we've got this dude wait in the windows
there is that. They'd dealt that'll,
that'll
definitely keeping near your phone.
Yeah,
but that's another beautiful
thing about the internet.
It's like that shit we were talking about
like he used to need a show like guys
used to go away.
If they didn't have a shelf,
they didn't have something to
put them out there to the crowd.
That's all gone away. Now you get
your own show. If you want to do,
you're great at podcasting.
You could just start a fucking podcast.
I thought about starting a podcast.
Totally. Should do a podcast.
You would have a hilarious podcast,
but you had a podcast.
I would for sure download that shit.
I subscribe to it 100%
I actually recorded six
episodes of a podcast.
It was called talking to strangers and
I just talked to legit people that the
people that had never met before or
that they weren't in comedy at all.
That's a great idea.
But then now,
I mean that would be me driving
the listenership every time.
Yeah. Which is, you know,
but still bill bird does a podcast where
he just talks by himself. Just him.
Renton. So does Greg Proops.
Greg does it alive. One,
he does a show called the smartest man
in the world. Yeah. It's hilarious.
Just him and he doesn't ask questions and
he does a lot of questions that mother
fucker could like no one.
Yeah, Greg Proops can,
he can just go and he's smart as fuck.
So he has like hours of information and
has had the dude has so much information
in his head. Like he went on
a rant about Columbus. Like,
I've read a bunch of shit about Columbus.
I knew quite a bit about Columbus,
but Greg Proops went on this mad rant
explaining what a cunt Columbus really was
fucking evil.
You know those people were back then.
Yeah, you can be evil back then
because there was no Twitter.
There can be evil and unchecked.
Facebook,
no Facebook, nobody like evil
Emma Evil Shit. Nah Shit.
Chill out.
Go on business holding a baby in one hand,
a sword.
You can just be evil because you just
had you an evil and you add to four
friends who also evil
enablers of life being evil.
Isn't that funny that that is the case,
the,
especially when you get to a new land,
like you getting a wooden boat and he
traveled to this half of the world where
it's going right in your eyes.
Completely wild, right. You know,
and they can come up with
all sorts of justifications,
why they should just start murdering
people and then they find out these people
have gold. Oh Shit. Yeah.
How's it been so easy to be evil back
then? You're actually right. Yeah.
Twitter keeps people from being as evil.
Well in Italian and attainers will
common called Columbus and entertainer.
But that's what I'm saying.
It wouldn't, I mean,
I don't know if he would have
been effective at whatever
it is something funny
to think about,
but yet it is crazy just just to be just
that type of that mind state that so
long ago it, we're going to this
place and we're gonna do some shit.
I Dunno if what we're doing
well, it's notorious when
someone shows up in a boat,
like this is probably the only time in
human history that when a boat full of
strangers shows up in your store,
people aren't going to die every
other time in human history.
Once that boat showed up,
most likely people were fucking dying.
Most likely some terrible shit's going
to get down some crazy desperadoes who
are starving to death.
I'm going to hop off that boat and
they're going to have swords and bows and
arrows and canons and they're going
to go cause they're hungry. Fuck yeah,
they're hungry. There's
that. Scurvy is no pussy.
They're eating rats and
fucking old rice. I mean, what?
What are they going to do when they
get off their, they're going to,
they're going to take whatever they want.
They're gonna, they're gonna go crazy.
Especially when there's no Twitter.
Yeah. Notes later to say, hey man,
chill a chill out on the pillaging.
I get the last hundred years.
Probably the only time where it's not a
terrifying moment when a boat pulls up
every other time before that, the 17
hundreds or whatever it was, what,
1492 Columbus sailed the ocean blue,
all that shit.
That was a terrible time when someone
pulled up in a boat. Terrible time. Boats.
A like, yeah. Tanks and then
tanks. Now when tanks pull up,
something bad is happening or it was
happening or it was about to happen.
Exactly. A battleship.
Yeah. Yeah. That's all
law.
Do you think they knew that something
terrible was going to happen right away?
Or was it they were, they
were open at first, right?
Well, did you ever see that
movie? There's a movie. Um,
I think it's what the bleep do
we know that try, I think it's,
this movie tries to present this argument.
They think that the native Americans
might not have even been able to see the
boat because they had no point of
reference, which is stupid as fuck. To me,
that would make no sense because there's
a lot of unique events that you only
see for the first time. I like the idea
that they wouldn't be able to see it.
It's,
I think it's just some woo woo bullshit.
I think it's some nonscientific bullshit
that some people try to pass off.
That's my take on it as a nonscientific
bullshit artist. Yeah. But, uh,
I think they wouldn't have known what
the fucker was if they had never seen a
boat before. And then all of a sudden,
like when the conquistadores landed, the,
the, the people who live like the Aztecs
thought that they were gods because they
never seen a person on a horse before.
They'd never seen that.
They didn't know what the fuck was going
on. They saw these people on horses.
They thought the horse was a part of them.
They thought they were gods.
I didn't never seen anything before.
It's crazy.
They think that a one point in time,
most of North America did not have horses.
The horses were brought
here from somewhere else.
So the native American Indians didn't
use to have horses in the beginning.
Wow.
Wait.
So they brought horses on these boats
or horses came from somewhere else. Wow.
So horse,
that was horrible boat ride.
Cause you talking about days and days
with a horse with a horse weeks and
feeding weeks,
probably
months,
right?
I mean how long did it take for Columbus
to get from Spain to The Bahamas?
I don't know. I don't know
how to be months. I would
imagine it would be months,
months of travel.
Monster travel makes sense.
When you're on a boat that has to
get blown around by the wind. You're
trying to get across the biggest
body of water known to man,
that Shit's ridiculous. Uh, ocean,
you gotta get across the ocean
on a floating piece of a tree.
That's the stupidest fucking thing
I've ever heard. So did you go
deal with horses?
So do you get to take everything was
you think he just felt inside out?
Just like man,
it was as loud as fuck.
I think people back then were ruthless.
I think they were dealing with completely
different times. People died younger.
The, the amount of time you were
on this planet was very short.
The average person didn't
get their shit together.
30 30 something you liked about it.
Was it,
I mean there was a few
people that live longer,
but most people probably
died off at 30 well,
and also the infant mortality rate
was so high that it lowers the, the,
the average age of death.
It lowers it because of that.
Like an infant mortality
was through the roof.
It was like 50% of the kids would die
back then. Like during the Roman times,
I believe it was 50% child mortality rain.
He had two kids.
One would be dead for sure. He's, yeah.
And that's normal. That was normal.
So I think their,
their whole idea of like what,
what's violent and what's
evil, what's good, what's bad.
It was just completely different.
They were used to way more barbarism,
way more murder, weight, the weight,
you know, they would Mary Antoinette,
they would,
they would fucking think about when
they would have those gigantic town
executions and they would use the gay
teen cut someone's fucking head off in the
town square.
We just think that people used to do that.
That was, that is, that
is, that is pretty. But
like we like now to Getty is kind of,
you know,
used as a joke in movies on stuff
like, yeah, the kids eat. But yeah,
the fact that that was real is insane.
It was real and it removed your head
and you were conscious for a few minutes
for you before you would die, your
head would be separated from your body,
your body would be dying.
But as the oxygen in your brain is
slowly leaking out like you are your
conscious for probably not a few minutes,
but probably at least a
few seconds we'll use it.
Man has fucked up looking up at
a basket and you're like, oh,
you gotta be fucking kidding. I
didn't do anything that bad. When you,
all you gotta do was pick the wrong
person off that had power and they would
just be off with their head.
It would just off with your hand.
That was like a common thing.
Can we talk, can we talk it through
a little bit? You need any work, work
done? No. Oh,
it isn't it funny too that they
would do that shit publicly.
Like that's what we avoid now. We don't
want the public even seeing coffins. Yeah.
Like you're not allowed to take
photographs of a coffins of veterans when
they're coming back. Yeah. The Bush
administration made that illegal,
which is kind of fucking crazy.
You're not even allowed to see a
picture of someone who dies at war.
Forget about c like a
prisoner getting executed.
You know a lot to see any of
that shit. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
I don't want to see that
prisoner getting executed.
If I sent you a link, you'd click it.
If I sent you a link and it says, uh,
you know, okay, let's just think
of someone just undeniably,
uh, Hitler. Okay. If I sent you a link and
it, dude, you want to watch this video?
This is a Hitler getting executed.
How's he getting executed?
It's going to get his head cut off
the sword. What mental state am I in?
Sova junk. Hi. Uh, depends on when
you get home. Uh, saying the email.
7:00 PM.
What other emails do I have?
And you had some new information about
your standup comedy special and to be out
on comedy central.
Yeah. On a, yeah, it's out on
comedy central direct right now.
It comes out midnight on a
Saturday on comedy central. Yeah.
Some information about that or,
or the Hitler thing. Oh yeah.
Click that Shit,
man.
Yeah, I'd click it to, I've clicked on
some shit. I shouldn't have clicked. Yeah.
The most recent one was um,
some Mexican dude cut in his girlfriend's
head off or cheating one of the drug
lords.
Like it's,
it's so obviously real as fuck.
So obviously really good.
His boys will,
who's filming it?
His friends. Yeah. It was one of
the cartel guys as crazy. You know,
there's some crazy cartel videos,
just cartel videos and I'm using chain
saws and cut and dude's heads off,
but almost,
I mean,
I know how fucked up it is to cut your
girlfriend's head off of cheating,
but in that you almost
understand. No, no, no.
I'm talking about in their world where
he's all about Latin machismo. Yeah.
It also be a cartel leader and your
girlfriend and everybody knowing this,
he cheated.
Like he has to maintain his Kartell Shit.
That's true. If you're going to be
awful, it's awful. Nobody's bugging.
Say Annabelle condones
beheading of cheating too late,
like know the right and the
salon.com right now, but
part of rape culture.
But that is that as is saying.
Do you have that up there?
I'm glad I didn't look.
Uh, we didn't have it up. Yeah, no,
no, we're not going to show you.
I don't want to see that shit.
Yeah, but that's, that's it. Cut.
He did a knife as recent. Oh
yeah. It's hard to watch, man.
It's really hard to walk.
Then you hold her head up.
The reason she was cheating is because
he was so busy running the carts.
I don't know what their history was.
What? I'm assuming he's in the wrong.
I'm sure running a card sale is very
time consuming and Sud needed some Dick.
He's still,
it doesn't mean that she didn't love him.
Yeah. I would say the same. If I was
there while this argument was going down,
he's like, I'm going to cut her fucking
head off. Like, dude, relax. You come on,
she's, she appreciates you. Let's kick it
was, she was just needed some attention.
She needed a little Dick. Come
on. Now let's look at it this way.
You got to fucking green light cheat.
However you,
they actually have the
green light and the cartel.
They just do whatever the fuck they
want. But yeah, at this point in time,
I mean how much money those
guys have their, I mean they,
they have cartels where the, the head guys
have like $1 billion. Like, yeah, this,
it's like make Al Capone look ridiculous.
Are we in
danger of being attacked by the
cartel now? I don't think so.
I don't think they've ever developed
like real legitimate military power.
But what they have developed as
local power, like they don't have no,
I mean me and you as individuals. No, we
haven't said anything bad. Oh, okay. Cool.
What did we said bad? I don't
know. They make a lot of money.
They don't tolerate
cheating. All right. Yeah.
So are we kind of cartel propaganda?
That's interesting.
If we were probably, if we
were cartel sympathizers, yeah,
but I don't think we are. I don't
think so. I think what we are is, look,
the whole reason why cartels exists,
but we were talking about earlier,
should cocaine be legal?
We'll have cocaine's not legal.
Who's going to sell it because people were
going to smoke it, snort it, smoke it,
whatever they do with it, shoot it. Some
people shoot it, they're going to do it.
They're going to do it. Who's
going to profit? Right? Criminals.
Is it better to have Pfizer or sell coke
or is it better to have the, the, the,
the mafia down in Pfizer. I say
Pfizer, I say led Pfizer profit off.
So Joe was just saying is
that if Kokei was legal,
this woman was still be alive.
You know what,
you might have a point there
I think. I mean, it's a long way
to go, but it does. You know,
I think that's what it is.
Well, I definitely think
some people would be alive.
Yeah. There would be less
violence, less violence.
It'd be less money
spent in jails on jails.
Don in Portugal is a clear indicator
that we're on the wrong path with,
with keeping everything
illegal and locking people up,
putting private prisons up,
throwing people in.
They're profiting off the fact
they're in their Portugal.
They've lowered everything.
They've lowered the rates of addiction.
They've lowered violent crime.
They lower the amount of money they have
to spend on legal fees and courts and
prisons. They load all that shit
just by decriminalizing all drugs.
They just made it so that people aren't
fucking locked up as criminals anymore.
Yeah. For a choice, choose alcohol,
which will fuck you up, man.
You and I. Okay. Listen, I was
in the apple store last week,
trust me, but we could get
fucked up in like 20 minutes.
Jamie could go back there,
breakout some whiskey,
and we could just start doing
shots within 15 minutes.
We would be unrecognizable.
Right.
You could get fucked up in like a short
amount of time with alcoholic or really
short amount of time.
Yeah.
Why is that legal and coke stock
by arbitrary. Completely arbitrary.
It doesn't make no logical sense.
There's no, it doesn't make sense.
The same type of person who would go on
a coat bench will also go on a drunken
rampage.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well you can't go on a coke
rampage. You go on both. Okay.
You can go on a a drunken binge.
Yeah, you can go on a drunken rampage.
You can go on a coke binge
or a coke rampage. Yeah.
Okay.
But I agree. I agree with you. I'd rather
be around the guy on coke. So there, well,
here you go. You got to a
drunk, you know, drunk problem.
Americans got a giant drunk problem.
We've got alcohol everywhere.
People die of alcohol,
but the hundreds of thousands
Savis [inaudible] all that shit.
What's better though? Coke drivers or
drunk drivers? I don't know man. I think,
uh, I don't know. I don't notice.
That's man. If you had to guess,
if I had to guess, would you rather be in
a car with a dude? Is coked up or dude,
he's drunk and he's driving.
I think
the cooktop, dude, we'll be driving fast,
but he'll make those lanes
shifts like a mother.
He'll be,
he'll be pulling right into parking spots
that you'd normally have to parallel
and so he just pulled
right in tight spots.
Slide two. Let's open up a driving
business. I'm fucking awesome.
[inaudible] we had to do cool drivers.
Cool man. When I was kid, I pass it.
The first time I tried I had to
written shit. The driver's shit.
I got all the information at
the knowledge. My got books.
I just need $100,000 come on man.
Let's do this. Let's make money.
Let's make money. Would be under year.
Come on man. We'll get some bitches.
Great. Yeah, he definitely,
I would talk to the coke guy first and
I would drive with the coke guy first.
Look at that.
Philoso I would, what am, I would
probably try to drive to, but that was,
that fucks up everything.
Oh, I would definitely
drive if I had the option,
it would be the guy driving over
the drunk driver or the coke driver.
Oh definitely. Yeah. But
if you couldn't drive for,
I'm injured and I need somebody to take
me to the hospital and only only person
is the coke for an audit drunk friend
Coke Fran. It's taken me to the hospital.
Yeah.
Or you're on the walking dead and you
get picked up on the side of the road and
you're just happy. It's not a zombie
dude is on coke. You got it wrote. Yeah,
I would definitely, if I had to
fight zombies, you'd want to do some,
I want to do this on coke with me
fighting zombies viewed on PCP a PCP.
Yeah. That's the kind. That's
the mother fucker you want.
But he would make your rational choices.
What about they do?
They do crazy shit,
but he'd be all right.
He had a string or met somebody
on maths fighting zombies.
That's a good move to which is like an
accelerated version of Adderall. Yeah.
Really? Yeah. Yeah, it is. Yeah.
Somehow or another related Adderall
put the teeth. The teeth part.
That's the real accelerated teeth part.
The teeth thing.
What do you mean teeth thing and
the destroying your face thing. Oh,
we would met with math. Yeah. Oh yeah.
Rots your teeth out. Brushing teeth out.
Just any form of speed.
Once they started doing speed,
I think they forget to brush too.
That's part of it. If I were to just,
[inaudible] is a real avid.
I haven't done that much research on
math because it hasn't affected my life
that much. Isn't that messed up? Let me,
sometimes I restart stuff that hasn't
had to deal with me, but meth mouth is a,
is a real is a real issue,
dude. It's in Wikipedia.
You're 100% right. Meth mouth
as is a turn by itself.
It is. Look, I'm lucky.
Pedia oh, it's horrible. Yeah.
Go to meth mouth on Wiki,
so I don't think there's anything called
Adderall mouth that's just dry mouth.
Do you drink a lot of water and
hydrate yourself? You embed a hill.
This is insane. Oh my
God. Sent in addition,
characterized by severe decay and loss
of teeth as well as fracture and namel
erosion and other oral problems.
Symptomatic of extended use of the drug.
Methamphetamine,
the specific cause that
condition is unknown.
Although drug induced Zeros,
zero stoma,
zero stomion Xerostomia or dry mouth.
Why don't just call it dry mouth.
Why you gotta get crafty?
Something I can't even
pronounce as well as Bruxism,
which is grinding of the teeth. I thought
to be involved. Wow, this is crazy.
They grind their own fucking teeth off.
That picture is a classic meth mouth.
You could tell by looking
at the other teeth,
a person isn't even that fucking old.
They just did some crazy shit to their
teeth. Yeah, I hope to party was awesome.
Poor nutrition, eating too much
sugar, lack of dental hygiene,
common among longterm uses of the drugs.
I didn't know that meth users eat a lot
of sugar, but that totally makes sense.
The legitimacy of meth mouth as a unique
condition has been questioned because
of the similar effects of
some other drugs on the teeth.
Treating meth mouth is difficult.
Yeah. Cause your teeth are
gone. You can't, but that's
the best treatment for math.
Math is uh,
veneers.
Yeah. You'd have to just chew them all
down and get some dental implants. Teeth,
some bulletproof teeth. Yeah, man.
Yeah. You're seeing a person has like a,
like a tooth where they do the
route they the gentle implant.
No, that does crazy veneers though.
I got TV teeth. You got some,
uh,
what'd they do?
They scrape the outside off and put a
beautiful shell these front and far as TV
teeth. Man, it's a beautiful, let me say
smile. Oh those are pretty, yeah man.
Did they make him perfect? Is that what
it is? That's how you got him. Yeah.
Cause I had a chipped tooth
then a gap and I was like, man,
I'm probably going to be on TV
a lot in the next few years.
Let me fix this real quick.
So I got it fixed in
2011 I got them fixed.
There's something sexy about a really
hot girl with a gap in her teeth.
Something like extra sexy.
I get girls would gaps used to connect
with me and like you got a cap.
I got a gap. I'm like, not for
long. It doesn't bother me though.
Does it bother you if a pretty girl
has a gap in her teeth? No, not at all.
Not even a little bit,
right? No, not at all.
It was just my own thing when I was like,
I'm to be on TV.
I don't want to have cracked teeth on TV,
but a gap is different than snaggle
teeth. Yeah. If there's all,
they're all snuggled up, my bottom teeth
are kind of snuggle. Yeah, sure. Fine.
One is one that goes back to fucked up.
I'm not going to get it fixed.
I'm a man. Okay. And my top
ones are, I don't give a shit,
but if I was a girl, yeah. Nobody wants
to look at us. Snaggley tooth mouth girl.
Yeah. It's just a yes. Natalie is.
Yeah. Snaggley is not a good look.
It's not good when you
get the extra teeth.
Those weird people that have extra
teeth that pop out of the gums and weird
spots. Yeah. S It's just, you know,
all men are not created equal.
Why don't we give a fuck? Why?
Why does anybody care about if someone's
teeth are not perfectly in line?
Like what is, what part of our brain is
being bothered by the lack of symmetry.
Yeah. It's just, that's what
it is. Is this symmetry. I
don't know what part it is,
but people like symmetry for
the same reason. It might,
I mean it wouldn't anger me,
but if this painting was like a
little bit off, it's a little bit off.
The other ones look down point, but
if it was a little bit off, I would,
I would notice it.
It would fuck with you.
Fuck with me.
I should tilt Jimi Hendrix noticeably
just to fuck with the next gas. Yeah,
just leave it there kind of cockeyed
and not say shit about it. Yeah.
I'm going to do that. Don't, don't tell
Adam Carolla I'm going to fuck with them.
I'm going to twist that shit up.
Yeah. So it's just, I think, yeah,
it's just the human brain likes, you
know, symmetry, symmetry. Perfect.
Lions you, Yup. Yeah, but why, but why?
I don't know. At a certain point in time,
logic should take over, but it doesn't,
there's certain shit just looks
good man. You know? I mean, just
like if somebody got a weird tooth,
it's just the same reason why,
you know, if your car got,
if your car got hit in the,
in the,
in the front headlight and smashed in
a little bit, the car still runs well.
But you want that shit
fixed cause it looks like
dumb. I agree with you 100%. I'm just
trying to figure out why. Why sit?
We like shit. It looks good man. I know
we do, but in that, why weird, right?
Like are you a car guy? Do
you like cars? I do like cars.
Like what's your favorite car
view? Faith. Actually
favorite. If they're listening.
I liked the Lincoln Mkx.
That's a beautiful car. A, yeah. I
liked that. Cuts of spaceship. Yeah,
I liked that car. And, uh, what else?
I mean I like some bins
is uh, yeah, it was,
will pull up the 2014
Mercedes Benz s class,
pull up a picture of this.
This is like a, you know,
if you think about like the cream of
the crop of like luxury automobiles,
like a Mercedes Benz.
Like there's no ugly Mercedes Benz.
They have a bunch of German scientists
that are fucking trying to figure out
what the symmetry is. Pull up, go
to do a Google search of silver,
2014 Mercedes Benz s class.
Look out this is there.
There's something beautiful about
it and escape Lee. Beautiful.
But when you look at the picture,
like why, like what the fuck is it?
Like what is it about that
sign? And it's just, yeah,
it looks slick as fuck of
that. That grill, that's
where it was a big part of it.
You can't say shit about that car.
No one could say that's not a good looking
car. Yeah, that's a masterpiece, right?
They,
they designed to make it smooth and
probably if you get in that car and drive
off your home, mother fucker
was going somewhere. Yeah.
Someone who sits in that car and they're
ad traffic. That's a guy who was doing,
or a gal that was doing well.
You have a beautiful car.
Looked at him and he was
Mercedes Benz. The smooth car.
Right. But probably brides.
Well
why does it look good?
Well why some things look good to
you and they don't look good to me.
Like here's something,
I have a friend who loves those
fucking stupid Mercedes. Uh,
those bread truck looking things.
Those old school ones are
little square cleanser or the,
what do they called? They look like
a jeep. A jeep. But it's, the bit is,
I think he's talking about us friends
or some people used to miss tour bus.
Oh No, that one. That put g five.
Yeah, that's the one. I take it back.
Mercedes doesn't make one AWG we car.
It's this one that's ugly as far I
wouldn't, I don't like, I guess it's just,
but sometimes the brand can take over.
It is totally take over it and it should
square as fuck. But people love it. Yeah,
I mean don't get me wrong, somebody
gave me one. I would drive it.
I'm sure it's lovely to drive. Mercedes
is their masterpieces of engineering.
But you know, look at that and then
like look at a new range rover.
You want to look at like a beautiful SUV,
pull up the image of the new range
rover and you see like a futuristic,
beautiful looking SUV. But
it's why, what is it? What is,
why do I like one or the other?
I've,
I never could figure out what it is that
appeals. I don't know what it is. This,
it's a, it's this varies by
person. Like I got these shoes,
a company sent me these shoes and they
send me some shoes that look great and
they send me some shoes and I'm like,
what the fuck? I would never wear this.
And so my little cousin,
she was visiting me from college,
he visited me in New York
last week and I was like,
look at these ugly fucking shoes.
They look like if Chester Cheetah
will a prideful and she was like,
those look great.
Those what I want to get those to my boy,
the whole shoes a Austin and I was like,
what the fuck?
And so it's just subjective, you know what
I mean? People, people, you know, people.
It's just subjective. It's some
people's eyes like different things.
Some people have different aesthetics
and just taste and that's what it is.
Cause I thought those shoes were
gross and I will never wear,
I still won't ever wear them,
but there's some people that might
like those shoes. I thought, yeah,
I'm totally with you.
I always wondered.
I want to see that's a new a look at the
difference between those two. This is,
this is a boxy in bread truck
and that's a space ship.
That's a beautiful spaceship. Yeah.
I've always wanted to know what you see.
Like anybody, any other person I was, I
assume that everybody sees what I say,
right?
I assume that you know when you're looking
at meth mouth you see the same thing
I'm looking at when you're
looking at these pictures.
But I don't know. You know,
I really don't know. I'm
just guessing. I mean,
imagine if you use somebody whose eyes
have you see through somebody and the
whole world. Completely
different. Totally different vibe.
What do you mean s c
just as far as the visual
or see as far as how people process
things. Both with the brain.
What else at totally different.
That's crazy. Oh, do you?
You'd probably use you smoke
so you probably like God,
do I look when I move around to other
will you ever see yourself on
video and you're like, Whoa,
what was that like that?
Oh Shit,
I was fat then I was a fat day.
Oh Man, I should've got a haircut.
Oh Man. My posture. I
actually, you know it's funny.
Well My,
I did a,
I did Letterman a couple of years ago
and I hate it cause my suit is horrible,
but now he's my suit. Horrible.
But my entrance is sucks.
I walk out on Letterman
and I'm like bounding Alec.
And I guess the word is no comp.
It means calm.
But isn't that like I don't look hot.
Thought I looked when I was walking out.
I'm like, yeah, I'm walking out on
Letterman and my mind and I see the video.
Can you pull it up? I seen the
video. I'm like, like it's not,
it's just like real heavy.
Look at,
maybe I'm over analyzing the too,
but that's sued is horrible.
I'm gonna get that garbage
suited and wrong with that
suit. That suit is garbage.
It's garbage about it. The fit
of it is tight. It's weird.
I think I buttoned the wrong button.
It's a weird fit.
I think it's fine.
Did you,
did you get crazy when you high when you
looked at this and get freaked out by
it? No. It's just when it like, yeah,
I mean me and my girlfriend
gives me shit about it sometimes.
Like she gives a shit about that
video. Yeah, it was horrible.
Or was another tie. What? Horrible suit.
Because I got better suits now
so I'll see it and I'm like, man,
that's suits sucks you a suit guy.
Do you get like your suits tailored?
I got my first tailored suit a few weeks
ago for this event idea for the Bulls
in Chicago, so I needed a
suit last minute, so I like,
I splurged on a suit and
got a nice one and it was,
it was killing and I'm making sure that I,
I wear as many events as I can just
to get my money's worth for the suit.
That's a sign of being a grownup man.
You get a nice suit. Yeah, it was.
He tell it there and it felt slick and it
was a, it was a smooth suit and it, it,
that's what made me realize that
my other suits with garbage.
When I put on a good suit, I was
like Internet. I'm like, this is,
this is how a suit should look. I looked
at the other shelter like, Oh fuck.
I was on TV like that.
My
every TV special I've ever done has
been like a tee shirt or you know,
largely tee shirt,
jeans.
Usually I don't want to trust in a way
that I don't normally dress where I'm
comfortable. Right. You know? Yeah.
I don't for my like for
TV appraisers just to,
or like a late night
shows like doing a set,
I'll put on a suit just to out of respect
for the show, you know what I mean?
But uh,
like for my special,
my first one I just want to button
up and then my latest one, I just,
I wore a jacket over,
a nice jacket over a t shirt.
What does this, this is amazing because
like that's just jeans and tee shirt.
Would you put a jacket? People like,
Holy Shit, you look great. Yeah.
Just what a jacket over my regular shit
jacket makes you look like
you're a professional.
But also it just makes people you like,
it's funny how close will determine how
people just approach you and just how
people treat you and how people talk to
you and how people respond to this shit.
You have to say like a jacket
or a suit and we'll just change.
Especially if you're a young man,
you know,
especially if you're like
a man in his twenties.
A guy in his twenties with a suit is
totally different than a guy in his
twenties but a tee shirt.
Yeah, it's, yeah, it is.
It's just you will elicit that person
seems more intelligent all of a sudden put
pitfall, more respectful.
They, it's weird that, that,
that that's like how did that, I think
about that too, like how did suits become?
How did that become the way
to dress? Like was one, dude,
I'm going to wear this and then
people were like, that looks good.
What do I get that shit? Yeah, dude,
who has like a suit and tie on and he's
holding a clipboard automatically take
them seriously. You take them
seriously. You defer to him.
I got to ask him something and let me
be respectful. He might shut me down.
He might ruin my life.
He might ruin my night.
The same kid with flip flops on and a tee
shirt, a pair of shorts, piece of shit.
How do you get this job? Who is
he? Yeah. Imagine if you went to
a Mercedes dealership and you wanted
to buy one of those beautiful cars.
Like I work in mine on the counters
wearing fucking flip flops and shorts and
wants to sign. He's telling you all this
crazy shit about Mercedes, Mercedes,
that the engineering is the finest
in all of Europe and what they do.
And you'd be like, I mean listen
to this fucking idiot was stupid.
I'm looking at it, look at
his feet, look at his toes.
He got something in between his toes.
But you know what I don't like is it
sometimes people will use that against you
where I'll stay at a
nice hotel and a person,
there's time people at the hotel,
it dress nice and they'll,
they'll take on a vibe like they
own the hotel. It was like relax,
relax a little bit. Oh Sir,
we do not allow that in,
in this shot to a mamoosh
ma. And I want to say, sir,
I think you make 30 to 50,000
a year comp that like they,
but they talk like it this way. Like get
a king, like Whoa, relax a little bit.
And so like maybe, and then maybe
if I had on a suit I'd be like, sir,
you shut the fuck up.
I'm also a suits right now.
That's true. Right, right.
You wear flip flops and
a dude is wearing a suit.
He automatically is one up in you.
And if you,
you could be a rich fucking dude
unless you got a crazy fat watch.
If you show up.
Yeah.
Have you checking in a fancy hotel
and you were in the flip flops,
but you got some stupid fucking gigantic
$20,000 watch on your arm and people
know it and you're gesturing
with your hands a lot.
And he says big fucking chunky
diamond crusted watch like a, okay,
we got to listen. And Scott.
Yeah, let them talk a little
bit. It's got some money.
But yeah,
I mean I think that's what I do.
I actually liked dressing horribly in,
in a high level situations like I love,
I get upgraded or I fly first a lot
and I love being in like jogging pants.
I love being a young
black dude jogging pants.
If first class people like,
Ooh,
I think it will fit it hat
on and my headphones and
people like what the fuck is
he?
How is he,
what do you think he
and my favorite thing,
I don't know what it is if
it's my demeanor or whatever,
but I like it cause I like mine.
Nobody ever talks to me at first
just about nobody. Nobody ever.
I'm always rich, rich, celebrity.
Nobody ever talks to me in first.
Where's my girl was,
she'll fly for like, I hear
about her, she'll tell it.
I talked this business guy was blah,
blah blah.
And now I'm at this rapper was on
the plane with me and this is like,
these people will just babble,
monster hurt,
Babel monsters or turn my cousin mate.
Well some people just talk to you when
you don't want them to talk like, Oh,
people monopolize the conversation babble.
But just people were just talking
obviously cause he's a girl.
But this is a funny thing where people
won't even engage usually with me on the
plane,
I got an ear beating from me and Tommy
[inaudible] girl. Do you know Tom Segura?
Yeah, me and Thomas Grower.
We're on a flight once. And
this woman who was the, uh,
the attendant on the flight,
she gave us the most unbelievable ear
beating I've ever experienced in my life.
It was just staggering. Good. Her Stamina,
her ability to not recognize clues,
the whole thing. She asked us,
we would like some wine and a,
we said a,
sure,
and I forget what Tommy asked for it for
that asked for Cabernet or Pinot Noir.
Like, do you have a, you know, you have
a, whatever you asked for a typical,
and she started cracking some
jokes about the movie sideways.
Do you ever see that movie? I have.
It's a movie about, um, it's with, um,
um, the dude from wings. That's
a fucking cool ass guy's name.
Fucking shit. What's his
name? The Dude Church. Uh,
what the fuck is this? Danny
Thomas Haden Church, uh,
who's a very cool guy actually. Um,
and uh, you know, it's all about wine.
It's just so she starts reciting this
scene. It's like that scene and you know,
blah, blah, blah. And then she goes,
well, I've never really been into wine,
but I'll tell you why.
There was a guy once that you know,
he had the bottle of wine he brings to
the rest and she's just going on and on
and on, and I'm not exaggerating like
15 minutes. She won't shut the fuck up.
She just hovering over this chair and
we're panicking. This is it. On a plane,
on the fucking plane. The flight
attendants on the fucking plane. Oh,
lean over the seat.
Just beating us into submission
with stupid ass story.
And so I start writing down, I, I'm in
the window seat and he's in the aisle,
so he's stuck with [inaudible] band in
him and just start looking out the window.
I was like, I can't do anymore.
I have to start looking
at the window. She won't stop. She's
just, she's worked her way from the,
the quote from the movie sideways to a
story about a dude with wine to story
about her ex husband and it's a fucking
murderer as a salt on the eardrum.
Tom was proudly so
punch drunk at the time.
We could think we said
it went to the bathroom.
Well, Tommy had a really
interesting point because Tommy,
I abandoned him and I left him to
to be slaughtered by her and he, uh,
he developed a psychological
profile of her and say, he said,
I think because we were on a small
plane, he was a small flight. He goes,
I think the reason why this lady's on
a small flight is because other ladies
don't want to work with her.
So they stick around the small flights
where she works by herself because she's
clueless.
She has no one to shut the fuck up and
everybody wants to get away from her.
I was sticker on these
little flights one hour,
hour and a half type flight
or something like that. Yeah.
It wasn't a very long flight.
Yeah. I forget where we're going,
but the beating that just,
yeah,
just brutal.
You're beating this broad gauge.
Yeah. It's tough and it's just, you
don't want to feel like a bad product.
Like is that even though in your
brain is this tough socially, but hey,
can you shut the fuck up? Oh he's
this, but it's this, it's tough to do.
Especially in a confined space like
that. Uh, in an air, in an airplane.
I mean in a social situation is
easier cause you can just say, yeah,
I'm about to go, go to the, go to the
bar, you need anything I'm going to get.
And they usually don't need a drink,
but that's the way to cut people off.
I'm going to get a drink.
Yeah. You or you say, excuse me, I gotta
use the restroom. I hate to be rude,
but I have to use the restroom.
And then I would just drop my phone and
start looking forward in between the
seat and hopefully would just, she would
find a reason to keep walking. Yeah.
But she would, she would do it not
just to us. She did it to everybody.
She decided to stop with. We watched her.
She went, she got done beating us up.
She went over to somebody else and beat
them up. So she was a social terrorist.
She was a terrorist,
wants to the terrorist one on that night.
I had to jump out real quick to the
bathroom. Go ahead man. Go ahead.
Don't worry about it. I'll tell everybody
about, uh, my show. I got coming up soon.
A lot of people, folks, they can't
handle these three hour conversations.
They don't develop the bladder control
that a man like me has. You know,
it's a man like me sitting here two hours
plus and I'm not feeling it. I'm fine.
Two hours and 10 minutes. By the
way, if you ever watch a UFC,
this is an inside joke
and you hear me talking.
Only me talking while the fighter is
walking from the back room to the cage.
That means Mike Goldberg went to pee
because my goal burpees like crazy.
I don't know what's going on with my
Goldberg. He tells me everything's fine.
I believe him,
but I have a hard time believing a man
can pee as much as Michael burpees.
I don't, I don't even understand it.
It doesn't even make sense to me. Like,
I'll go to take a leak,
don't get me wrong because um,
a lot of times I'll have
a cup of coffee there.
I'll have a couple of bottles of water.
You want to keep hydrated while
you're screaming and yelling.
So I will get up and go to take a leak,
but I'll do it.
And then an hour later,
like he'll do another one,
like we'll go together and this motherfuck
will pee again inside of an hour.
And I don't know how he does it,
but heal the most he ever did so far.
You know in a UFC event is six,
he peed six times.
My cohost in UFC,
Mike Goldberg,
who's a Great Guy But likes to pee.
So apparently he enjoys running out
to the bathroom and taking lynx.
Was he drinking a lot of waters?
He just says a lot of water and drinks
red bulls and shit like that too.
While we're doing the broadcast is taken
off six times an hour. No, in a show.
And it's showing a whole UFC show,
which is like six hours where the
fights hot us. I mean if he's, you know,
sort of still ridiculous man, you know,
this is what you're doing. Sit down.
Yeah. If you do it, I
guess if you do a TV yeah.
Strengthen your pee. Yeah.
But uh, for, you know,
just for most people as they get older,
apparently that becomes an issue.
Dude's develop prostate problems and
your, your, your prostate enlarges.
I know this because I
had to get my dog fixed,
my dog's prostate and large so
much that it was constipated.
That's your dog fix was a,
a metaphor
prostate. And I noticed how I get that
shit. Is this, what happens after four?
Doug was six and he's uh, he's um,
he developed a enlarge prostate.
I had to get them fixed shit.
Johnny Cash no longer has balls.
He seems happy though.
He was,
he was actually getting constipated
because of it was really interesting.
Like it was blocking up. Was pinching.
Where's Colin is. Yeah. Poor dog.
They, uh, when I was on that a
goat farm, a worker with them,
they had, they had me, uh, I was milking
the garden and they brought one gold in.
They had me bring, there's
this one young, uh, male goat,
anything like you want to name
them? And I was like, yeah,
name names [inaudible] they're boy.
You sure? And they're like, yeah.
And in a band they were like,
we're going to band them and they put
a band around his balls. And so Ebay,
they do like a delay. Castration
isn't that like they cut it off.
They, they put the band on in
the is fall off two weeks later.
But I didn't like that they told me,
they sent me up to name him.
Uh, and then they were
like, and now, yeah,
he's not going to have balls in a little
while. Like that's pretty shitty. Yo.
Well they were going to do that anyway.
They were going to do it anyway,
but they didn't have to have
me hold him as they did it.
Yeah. That's kind of fucked.
Yeah. To them it's normal.
Yeah. But no, it was, I mean, I
guess it will be all right TV,
but after she kind of made me feel weird.
You know, human beings do that
to themselves sometimes too.
That's like one of the ways that men
castrate themselves is that they use like
rubber bands and tighten it all
up and it all just goes dead.
Then they saw it off.
Wait, who? What type of duties?
I castrate in themselves.
A lot of crazy fucking people out there,
man. There's um, there was a wedding,
a website called a BME
extreme that's from the,
there's a video,
the BME pain
Olympics. See that acronym?
Yeah. I don't know.
Apparently there's no real pain Olympics.
It's not real,
but they called this video. The BME
don't pull that up, but there's a,
a video of a bunch of dudes hack and their
dicks off and cutting their balls out
and people have done it. It's definitely
happened. And they've done it on video.
This people have cut their fingers
off on video and put the video online,
cut the tip of their finger off with a
sword. People are fun. Yeah. It's crazy.
One off activities. Yeah. You want,
can't repeat that repeat last.
Just champion. That's a one
off. It wasn't worth it.
Some weird thing where some people like
to do that for whatever reason they want
to, they want to castrate
themselves like they, like it's,
it's more common than not. In fact, you
know, that's what they're trying to,
you know,
release themselves from
this Bin is one sec.
So much like, you know, the
way I deleted my Twitter APP.
Exactly. And, but then they realized
they wanted it afterwards. But you know,
I can reinstall Twitter. We'll, you know,
supposedly I had read
this about Nikola Tesla,
the famous inventor that he did something
he didn't explain, explain what he did,
but in quotes destroyed his sexuality.
He had some really confusing,
uh,
love situation with some woman apparently.
And he just got it just ruined everything,
ruined his life, ruined his work.
He just got messed up with some
chick and then decide to, in quotes,
destroy his sexuality.
And I don't know if that's true or not,
but you're talking about a guy and Nicola
Tesla who was a crazy genius inventor
who also was in love with a
pigeon thought this pigeon.
He was like in love with this pigeon
and this weird romantic interest in a
pigeon before he died.
He said completely off the rails.
So does he deserve to have a
car named after him on that?
He's a bad motherfucker. He wasn't. No.
It's crazy. If humans are never perfect,
no one knew.
No one retires with an undefeated record.
Not even Floyd Mayweather along the
way, he takes some losses, losses,
and uh, you know, making
out with a pigeon never
made out with it.
I think he just was in love with a
picture of what it visit and destroyed his
own. Again, that's what I
read. That could be propaganda.
I'm exposing propaganda left and rights.
It might be, might be propaganda.
Might not be real. Like Napoleon did,
you know, to Polian wasn't short. Whoa.
That's a mind fuck. In fact, he was
taller than average for the time. Please.
He's like five, eight, five, six, five,
six. Yeah, for France. Let's find out.
Napoleon. Napoleon Polian
is real height, but I mean,
that's a standard, right? Oh,
he's got an Napoleon complex.
A standard five foot six.
Yeah.
So back then when people have
no fucking nutrition whatsoever,
that was actually taller
than average. Okay, so,
so the Polian complex,
this means
you want to take all of this shit?
Yeah, it depends. This actually,
this one actually says 5.7
it's five five foot, seven inches.
This one says whatever it was for.
Then back then,
that wasn't nearly short as it is now.
Like I'm five eight and I'm short for
today for 2014 when people have good
nutrition. Yeah, but back then
that was actually a tall guy.
Like there was a regular size guy.
There was like a guy was like five 11 wow.
Yeah, it's like normal.
Maybe not even five of this.
Five 11 five 10 what
does average five nine,
seven or something like that in five.
Eight oh, sorry, I'm about five.
10 let's find out. I got
him. Napoleon complex.
What's the average height?
What's the average American
height? What's the average?
Okay.
Male American.
All right. Okay. Let's
see. I'm saying five nine
yeah.
The average us is five.
okay.
Oh, the average. Yup. Yeah, no. Yeah,
that's, yeah, that's what is that average.
So they're saying, is that that higher,
taller than average? What do
you think the average would be?
Maybe? Well, this one thing says five,
10 average male American height,
average female, male s, uh,
is five foot 10 inches. Okay.
Yeah. It says, here's another one,
and us mail five foot 10 inches.
I'll take it.
I haven't done as much research as is
this. I was just feeling me and my friend.
Well, I think it goes up. I think it's
gone up definitely since I was born.
And I think part of it is nutrition.
People understand things and they also
noticed stand not to smoke when you were
in the womb. I think that's, fuck,
that's fucked. A lot of kids up.
A lot of women used to smoke when they
were, they were probably, my mom smoked.
Yeah. Yeah. She's pulling from me and
my sister. She apologize to you. Nope.
We don't bring it up really well. She got
to do apologize for the PAG. Yes. Right.
Let go cause a fight. It go. Okay,
now it's, yeah. Yeah. Basically.
Basically, almost every one
of these studies shows it's
about five foot 10 from,
for for now.
Okay.
In the U s which is interesting
because it's definitely gone up,
uh, over a c, what does that average,
this is the Netherlands, the USA,
France and Japan. Average man.
So Japan is the shortest with BMI.
And Japan's changing too though, man.
There's a lot of much bigger dudes,
Japan now than there was like during the
World War II days. They're way bigger.
So what is the less,
the theory behind, uh,
Japanese to having a short is, is
it just because they don't, uh,
mixed with other races as much?
And so it's just genetics could be,
um, it could, there's a lot
of factors. It could be,
it could be also that it's an
island. You know, it's not,
not the biggest place in the world.
You know, it's not a tiny island.
It's not like re unreal islands,
like real small places.
They have a thing called island
dwarfism or things on that island. Uh,
like that's if you are seeing that,
that a little creature that
they found Homo Floresiensis,
he's the hobbit man that they found
that lived like 14,000 years ago.
We'd never seen that. Oh,
fascinating shit, man.
14,000 years ago there was little people
that lived alongside human beings that
looked just like you or I, and there
were these little tiny like hobbit,
like creatures. They're like three feet
tall and they were a type of human being,
not like human, not like Neanderthal,
pull up the images. Like there's an,
there's an image of a homo floresiensis
that they made the hobbit man and uh,
this in this island of Flores,
they found one and they thought it was
like maybe a child's bone or something
like that.
But then they realized that it was
structurally different than a human beings
and they thought it might've
been just an aberration,
like someone who had some
sort of a disorder and then
they start finding more of
them and they found out that
they buried their young,
they would find like little graveyards
and shit. They found stone tools.
They realize they use tools and evidence
of use of fire. Pretty, pretty insane.
She has crazy, that's not that
long ago, man, to 14,000 years ago.
And what's really crazy is there's people
that think that there's something like
that that's still alive today. She's at
a small, they're small islands. Yeah.
See that's,
that gives you an idea of it,
but there's some good
images of those things,
but then you see like with
the neander tall gorillas,
human beings like look how little those
fucking things where they were a type of
people. Right. That's freaky
shit man. That is true. Yeah.
And it's real thing.
I mean it really existed.
What is the big guy on the far right?
Not In the end to all,
but the guy who just don't,
yeah, it was that dude. Jesus.
That's a big fucking dude.
That looks very apelike too.
Like look how long his arms are as
Jesus. What's it say? I can't read it.
Yeah, whatever it is. We
glad we moved past that.
Those dudes would be running shit.
They were still around.
That looks like a combination of like
a homosapien and like almost like a
gorilla like extra long as arms are.
I mean it might be just
the artist depiction.
It looks like a scary cat to run
into on the SAVANNA. Fuck all that.
Well apparently there was a,
a bunch of um,
people that lived in
Russia too is recently as,
I think it was 40,000 years ago that
were completely different than then
homosapiens to another, a different
site thousand, 40,000 years ago.
Didn't NCS or something like
that. Here, let me pull that up.
A Russian new type of person,
type of human 40,000 years ago.
Have you been to Japan before?
Yeah, it's amazing. It's incredible.
It's a really interesting
place because um, it's,
it's first of all incredibly clean and
unbelievably polite and like really
almost crime free completely.
Like when you walked on the streets,
you don't worry about shit every,
I mean you're in a major metropolitan
area like Tokyo and it seems like the most
peaceful place on earth. Very little
aggression. Everyone's very polite.
People are like, like
whether it's shopkeepers are
restaurant owners are like,
when you're walking on the street,
you don't have any sense of chaos like
you have in New York City, Israel or the,
oh, that's cool, man. Yeah.
Foe, here's it is, it's in a,
is in the National Geographic Dna reveals
lost relative from 40,000 years ago,
Russian researches dug up,
uh,
a sliver of human finger bone
from an isolated Siberian cave.
The team stored it away
for a later testing,
assuming that the nondescript fragment
came from one of those neanderthals, uh,
who left a,
a welter of tools.
I don't even know what a welter is and
I haven't heard that expression well to
alter of tools.
So that'd be,
yeah.
Yeah. Well, no. Have
you ever heard of that?
What's l w e l t e r welter of tools.
And it came between 30
and 48,000 years ago.
And nothing about the
bones seemed extraordinary,
but the genetic material
told a different story.
When the German researcher is extracted
and sequenced the DNA from the fossil,
they found that it did not match that of
neanderthals or of modern human beings,
which were also living nearby at the time.
So a new genetic data reveal that
the bone may belong to a previously
unrecognized extinct human species that
migrated out of Africa long before our
known relatives. That's
all 40,000 years ago, man,
there was a different
type of fucking human.
They went to Russia that was in
Russia. In Siberia. Africa. Yup.
So Africa sucked back then. Well,
people always keep walking, dude.
They just keep going. That's
just within us. We keep going.
I guess maybe people got to California
and then they decided to move to Maui.
Like this. Just keep on going. They
got direct flights to not back then.
Just boats. Crazy. Yeah. That
wasn't, was that Bolts Beck?
That was this 40,000 years ago.
Most likely no boats is straight up
walking and walking and walking. Yeah,
they're starting to fucking
backdate boats though. They've uh,
they've backdated boats quite a bit.
I think they found evidence of a tuna,
like oldest evidence of tuna, like way
earlier than they ever thought. Oldest,
no tuna boat,
tuna boat.
They're magic. The first dude
that make a boat was like, man,
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
I don't even know where to go.
Well, they had it. Wow, dude,
sweat this. They had boats.
They were fishing boats and three 10 a d
the earliest known boat was made.
It's a 7,000 year old boat found in
Kuwait as the earliest known boat,
but now they found evidence
of deep sea fishing.
42,000 years old,
a bolt.
This is the newest shit that will,
they found evidence of, of a,
of tuna bones
and tune our deep sea fish.
So someone had to out there
and get these motherfuckers.
The earliest known bolts found in France
and the NFL are only 10,000 years old,
but archeologists know that
they don't tell the whole story.
Would in other common boat building
materials don't preserve well and the
archaeological record and the colonization
of Australia and the nearby islands
of Southeast Asia,
which began at least 45,000 years ago,
required sea crossings of
at least 30 kilometers.
So they know that 45,000 years ago
someone had a boat that could go about 60
miles, right? Isn't that
what it is? Kilometers.
100 kilometers of 62 miles. I know
the opposite. So it's less kilometers.
Less than a mile? Correct.
Okay, so a little bit. A little
bit more miles than that.
Like double? Yeah. Hundreds. Yeah. Wow.
That's crazy.
Yet whether or not these migrants put it,
is that how it goes? Cause kilometer
and how many kilometers again? How many?
30 kilometers or 30 kilometers.
Just 20 miles. Okay. Okay.
So it's less miles or less
than kilometers, right? Right.
Cause a hundred kilometers an hour
is 62 miles an hour. All right. Okay.
So 30 kilometers,
probably 2020 ish miles in a boat.
45,000 years ago.
Yet,
whether these early migrants put out
to sea deliberately in boats or simply
drifted from the tides in rafts meant
for near shore exploration as a matter of
fierce debate. So they at least
had that, this is crazy, man.
That's crazy that they think people were
deep sea fishing 40 fucking thousand
years ago. People had to eat.
Yeah, but I mean it's amazing.
They've found half of the
fish in these areas, um,
that these people lived in, uh,
off Australia 42,000 years ago.
Half of the fish they found were a tuna
and sharks that live in deep water.
They also found a fish hook from
a mollusk shell, a mollusk shell,
and dated it to 23,000 years ago.
That's incredible.
People were fucking doing some
crazy shit back then, man.
People are hungry and they
were tired of deer. Yeah.
And well cows and like we were saying,
man, they just, they keep going.
People keep going. They came here for
fucking Africa. Even if they, this, these,
these dudes that went from Africa all
the way to Siberia and then they died
there. Was it that hot? It was
the heat that did it right.
Could be a million,
no food competition,
no food driven away by predators,
driven away by other humans who knows.
Mature in a way that fight,
we got to keep it. There's a lot
in between Africa and Russia.
And if they were doing it on foot
fucking a man 40,000 years ago,
they might've been doing it on foot.
It's very possible.
They probably might not have even
had horses just walking let's shoes.
They probably figured out choose
right or they might not need them.
Leif leaf feet. I Dunno.
Have you ever seen that show?
Uh, I forget what it was called.
Dual survivor or something like that.
And there was two dudes and
they would go wandering around,
surviving in the woods.
Like their whole thing was survive.
And like they would do a
thing like survivor man,
but there was two of them was a
competition. No, they would just survive.
They would just show you how you would
create a a house and this is how you go
catch fish and this is how you
protect yourself from rainstorms.
But one dude, everywhere he went, he
would go barefoot. His name was Cody.
I think Cody,
he's got the nastiest feet of all time.
He is like thick calluses all over the
bottom of like a shoe because he never
takes his fucking, he never puts
his shoes on. He walks everywhere.
So the skin on his feet,
it was just hard as a rock,
Eh, this is disgusting. Pretty disgusting.
Proudly when he comes to people's plays,
they asked him to put shoes on.
Yeah, they come out, Cody,
Cody's coming over your house
and give him your slippers.
They know he keep him and keep him,
man,
you got to cover those fucking nasty feet.
I eat in this house.
I don't know what's flying off of your
feet while you're wandering around.
That is nasty. There's something
particularly offensive about feet.
Like someone can have some,
you know,
you could have dry skin on your forearm
and it doesn't really bother people,
but if you got some, that's his
foot. He's rolling with a rock.
Why is he running it with?
Is that a callous or like some type of
fungus, that white thing. Oh, that's a,
what am I looking at? Foot. But
no, it's two other things there.
It's a big toe. Okay. What does that,
that's his toe and his rap. Yeah. I think
what he's doing is his polling is tall,
rubbing it with a rock to make.
I thought the white part,
I stopped. That was too much.
If I get hard, I'll get scared.
I don't know why I made that choice.
I'm sure he knows about shoes.
It's gotta be a more effective strategy.
Marketing.
What does stand out to stand out
from the other? Gavi, more memorable.
Get mentioned on the Joe Rogan
podcast. That's a good point, man.
It did work out because the other dude,
nobody knows who the fuck he is. Yeah.
That's so true. Marketing is
so important. Like what it was.
Everybody know about Einstein's
got this fucking crazy hair man.
Not just equals MC square. They know what
he looked like. It's all wild and Daddy.
Yup. Nikola Tesla. No one knows
that. That dude looks like nope. Why?
Because he was a slick little Croatian
dude. Very slim or wear a suit and tie.
Look normal. Yeah. Nobody
gives a fuck about that guy.
Nobody plays Nikola Tesla for Halloween.
But people would dress up like Einstein.
Everybody knows you're Einstein. Exactly.
You're right. Got To get you to look.
Have you ever thought about a look like
perhaps like maybe something that people
will remember?
You mean you're talking about a case,
a catchphrase for a pig hunting? Maybe.
Maybe you need to like, you know,
something.
What type of outfit or
something? Yeah. Uh,
get the same outfit time.
Nobody ever done that same outfit.
Yeah. Like a Bruce Lee outfit. Oh,
like a Bruce Lee out? No. Bruce Lee,
where that game of death outfit.
And if you see anybody in a yellow
track suit with black stripes,
you automatically think of Bruce Lee.
Remember we fought Kareem Abdul Jabbar.
He had the track suit. I don't remember
if it was, don't remember, dude.
I see nursing that tracksuit.
Come on.
I haven't seen a lot of the
essential movies or television.
I know has seen Bruce Lee movies.
I see it.
A couple Gabriel Iglesias as a comic
that does that with his shorts.
That's a good point.
And he has the,
he has the in a silhouette of him
behind it as part of his stage set. Oh,
does he always?
Yeah.
I always shorts and a Hawaiian shirt
or something and always a silhouette.
Even when he's at clubs, not a
silhouette but like a, like a,
that logo will be behind them.
And now I'm talking about for
specials on TV for a special. Yeah.
And probably if he played,
he played, he's like, yeah,
he was places so probably had some
type of set piece or something.
He does huge places. Any does clubs
too. Like Gabriel, we'll do like a,
he'll do like nine shows in a
week and do like a 6:00 PM show.
He'll do an 8:00 PM show, a 10:00
PM show and a midnight show. Yeah,
he's crazy like that.
He does a early shows for kids.
Like families can come to like a 5:00
PM show when it's light out. Wow. He,
I think he holds the record for the most
consecutive sellouts at the ice house.
Sold out like some insane
amount of shows in a row.
Like he was there for two weeks in a row,
like every day does Monday
night shows and shit.
I haven't seen him live. I've seen
he brings a lot of people with them.
Brings like a lot of stand ups. Supports
a lot of dudes. Yeah. Just he, he like,
you know, supports the, he's a genuinely
good guy. Like a, as far as like,
I remember, uh, Trevor Noah used to tour
with him and he traveled and he gave her,
he was like,
you gotta get merged man.
And so Gabriel got them some certs made
up and then Travis said he was killing
it on Mertz after shows and shit.
Yeah. People love to buy shit.
If you've got a catch phrase,
that's something Bam,
Bam will eating him.
Joe Rogan need to make
one man. Come on, dude,
do it. We'll go. We'll take you pig
hunting and when, when you kill a pig,
you got to say that. Yeah.
That'll be your shit.
And then we'll start making tee shirts.
Definitely.
You don't get high when you hunt.
Do you know?
I mean, I know people who do. I know
a dude who dear Hans. Hi. Yeah. Yeah.
He likes it. He's an old
hippie. Yah. The smokes.
A little weed and cause out there and
we ain't don't look like a Hippie,
but there's a lot of hippie in him.
He loves to take a one hitter,
take a blast and then go out
and go hunting. She was like,
you're more in tune with nature.
Yeah. I feel like if I shot an animal
high, I freak out. Like, oh no,
just taking life.
It was was alive now because
of my actions. It is alive.
Yeah.
It pretty common probably.
Yeah,
but you wouldn't get bummed out if
you went and bought a cheeseburger.
If I went to in and out.
You're so disconnected from the process.
Just deliciousness.
This is real fast too.
Do you think that's a part
of human evolution is that
there's a reason why we're
moving past this whole hunting gathering
thing and that in the future that not
only will not be necessary, but like we
won't even have those desires anymore?
No, I think it's, this is a convenience
man. People got jobs as shit.
We can't be shooting
pigs for sure, for sure.
But your lifestyle can sustain that.
That you know,
going out there and waiting for
two hours and taking a side,
it's good at it and then cutting it and
putting it on the grill and doing all
that. That is cool. But you know,
the reason food is processed,
how it is is just because people don't
have time to be fucking with that.
Absolutely. I mean people with regular
jobs absolutely don't have time,
but there's also people don't
want to be a part of it. Yeah.
People are moving away from
it and I wonder if that is
all a part of the process
that's going to lead people
to develop artificial food.
It's just like food that you get from
animals because they've already figured
out how to do that.
They've already made science.
They figured out how to make some
sort of an artificial steak and it was
unbelievably expensive,
like $250,000 or something like that
to create this meat that they grew in a
test tube or in a laboratory somewhere.
But I think that maybe like that's
like the first echoes of this sort of
cultural shift from,
from being hunter gatherers to being
able to go to the grocery store too.
There's no need to kill an animal because
we're going to make artificial meat
and everybody would just eat
scientifically created meat that's totally
nutritious and healthy.
They'll fuck it up for a couple of
years and some of it will, you know,
some people get like some weird crones
disease and shit like that from the
artificial meat,
but then eventually they'll get it down.
So it's even more nutritious
than like wild game.
I don't know if I want to go that route.
I don't know either.
But I think it's inevitable. Yeah. Yeah,
I think so. I think there's a reason why.
Um, I think it's the transition. There's
a reason why people find hunting.
Just tasteful. Even people,
some people that eat meat,
they don't even want to
know how the animal dies.
They don't want to be a part of it.
They don't want,
they certainly don't want to see a video
and they definitely don't want to go
shoot an animal. Right. So why do they
like meat? Like why are they so good?
It's delicious, but why are they okay
with that? Cause I think there's like,
that's like the bridge between
us and then the new us,
which just figures out how to do
everything synthetically just recreate it.
Just like they could recreate every,
I mean they're going to
recreate people for sure.
If we stay alive for
another thousand years,
if human beings are still on this planet,
a thousand years from now,
we will have artificial humans
that are indistinguishable.
It'll be some a hundred
percent blade runner shit
about, yeah, I feel like a thousand
years is going to get weird. I kinda, I,
I sometimes I think about the future and
give bummed out that I won't get to see
how crazy
it is. You might just based on how it
is, the shift has been doing my lifetime.
You say I might, you might,
it might be so crazy.
You might actually get to
see 500 years from now.
Bullshitting man. The, the, the,
if you pay attention to guys like Ray
Kurzweil and all these futurists that are
at the cusp of technology
that really understand the,
what innovations are being created,
all the different things they
have on the pipeline. Yeah.
They're getting pretty close
to getting pretty clear.
They say that the person that's alive
today is going to be the first person to
live to be 150 years old.
Yeah.
And they think that that's just today
that that person will probably be alive to
meet a person lives to be a thousand.
I just ended that. I just made that up.
Let me see if it is only made up the
part about that person will probably be,
yeah, but the 150 thing, that's pretty
much consensus. 50 I mean that's a lot,
but yeah, it feels more feasible cause
what is the latest had been 117 hundred 20
something like that or it's hard to
tell because it's hard to find out who's
telling the truth when
they get to be that old.
Those are all constantly to fuck a
paperwork. Fuck, they ain't got nothing.
Nothing to lose. The weight
is going to challenge them
like, yeah, you do look, oh,
his foot. We believed
you. What's the point?
Society needs this story. Anyway.
Yeah. Who is, let's take a guess.
I'm going to say 122 years old.
Oh,
the Otis and I think is one 17
one 18 is the oldest person.
Let's find out right now.
Oldest person ever was 116 years old,
oldest living person.
The oldest ever was 122 oh wow.
Yeah. She's from France. What about
the, what about those Bible folks?
Oh, the 600 year old know.
What about those folks?
Well, I think their calendars
with dog shit back then.
They will talk about weeks.
Calendars. We've written down stones.
Happy Birthday is Monday. Yeah.
The idea that those people lived 600
years. That's Hilarious, but what if,
what if back then what was going on is
they were super technologically advanced
and then the flood came along.
They had to start from scratch.
It would have no,
really was
600 years old because no was a part of
an ancient civilization that was far more
advanced. That's why God got
pissed. These motherfuckers,
these dummies are living to be 600
years old. All right. Fuck this.
I'm just going to start with Noah.
I'm just going to know.
You seem like a good guy, but
yeah. Well it's ridiculous.
It's also ridiculous that we are
the children of Noah's incest.
Yeah. Was it? No. Was it
assessed? Who else is who,
who fucks? I mean, how many people were
left? It's no one. How many people?
His family,
right?
Oh, you mean, oh, you mean?
Yeah, his incest. Uh, yeah.
I mean he didn't bring her on a bunch
of hot Swedish chicks for excellent
genetic material on the shoot
loads and to all of them, he,
even if he did just that small gene pool,
have no abroad over 50 people
and just fuck those 50 chicks.
It was just him in 50 checks.
The whole human race would be a mess.
The whole human race.
It's all crazy.
Interbreeding or that w would take
generations to fucking fix all that shit,
right? Yeah. Yes. Nah, I'm not
a, that stuff is all goofy.
It's goofy stuff is definitely
goofy. But, uh, uh, there,
there still is this people to this day,
it's still believe it have giant,
a giant percentage
giant. That's 100%. It's very
passionate about it. So it's a,
I try not to get into it with those
types. What do you know? I mean, I don't,
I don't,
I'm never in situations where I'm talking
with a religious person or debate.
I talk about it and my stand up a little
bit and uh, pretty much that's it.
But it is, it does baffle me a little
bit. When people get mad on Twitter,
the world's go up to the Muslims.
You always go on after us Christians,
first of all, because Muslims are
a more dangerous target. Dummy
pretending it. And second of all, because
you're right here, you're right here,
right here in America, land of the
free home. They believe in zombies.
Family as Christa's. Yeah. More relatable.
I grew up Christian. So is this
a different yeah. Yeah. This is,
uh, this is also a much more ridiculous
place to get hoodwinked. You know,
we're not living in some backwards
fucking crazy culture that's run by some,
well, sort of are, but not as
much. So as these ancient cultures,
there's cultures that have been,
you know, they're, they're,
they have a lot of their ideas about
what people shouldn't, shouldn't do,
or thousands of years old.
They just stuck him. Right.
Yeah.
This is really weird that I talk about
people getting the Holy Ghost sometimes.
You all, that's great. I love that
the Pentecostals and a baptist,
when people just like
really
that are you doing that is that,
that it makes you feel like that the
Lord makes you, Dan speaking in tongues,
speaking in tongues.
Is that you did you,
did you just want to do
that and use this hat,
this excuse using religion as an excuse.
Like I used to speak at what does,
is this,
that s that's confusing when it's just
when they were living in turns into a
reason for people to just act
out and be weird publicly.
I like when they do it on TV. You ever see
Robert Tilden? You know, that guy is uh,
probably by face if he's a,
if he's a religious dude,
he's one of the most ridiculous
all time dudes. But uh, he,
he would like in the
middle of it broadcast
hosts. So solar, Macula, it just totally,
completely obviously fake language.
And he was making it up on the spot.
Very repetitive.
Very unlike a real language.
It varies and tone and,
and sounds and creative with some alarm
keeps repeating the same sounds
over and over again. Stinks.
Because I can understand.
I understand the structure of it as him.
Is he speaking in tongues here?
We'll also
provide and multiply. That's the
opening of the windows of heaven.
This is, oh, this is the
farming preacher video. Yeah.
I want to hear him talking in tongues.
Yeah. They putting fart sounds while he's,
it's very juvenile.
Youtube is free.
There is, yeah. I'm gonna take this
preacher fart sounds. Gunshot noises.
You know what this needs,
I'm until a super cut of
this, but I'm gonna put this song over
it so it looks like he's singing to this.
You know what else?
The Internet figured out that uh,
people outside the Internet ever
figured out memes. Those memes. Yeah.
Pictures like a picture, a picture
of you. Bam, Bam. We're eating ham.
I mean that's without a
doubt someone has made that.
It's already happening without a doubt.
I'll go to my message board right
now and I guarantee fucking tee you.
There is a photo up on my
message board that says Bam, Bam,
we're eating ham and it shows you and if
not you cause times phrase both of us.
You,
you said it man,
but I'm not a hunting.
I don't need it man. I'm
it.
I ghost write sometimes and he said it.
You said it. It's up there man. Without
a doubt. I guarantee you it's up there.
It was not up there.
By the end of this broadcast,
someone will at least be working on it.
That's the beauty of the Internet.
It is crazy. Oh, it's the
greatest thing ever, man.
We're so lucky as comics to to,
to be able to release specialists
and shit in this time. Yeah.
Like your special is going to be on
comedy central Air Saturday night. Yeah.
But it also, you could get it online
right now. Right. Right. Foot up.
People that don't want to wait, they want
to go get that shit by the way. Get it.
And can you play it on iPads and
everything? It's everything. Yeah.
You can play it on your phone. Everything.
I think phone also. Yes. Beautiful.
That's beautiful. Yeah. See, look at
that. This is a beautiful time for,
for standup distribution. Instant
access where we could say, hey man,
Hannibal's a funny motherfucker. You
need to go see live from Chicago. Boom.
Someone to go online and at the end
of my sentence, they're already in.
They're already clicking in and yeah,
it's incredible. Is a good sign. Yeah.
Making it out.
Boom.
And that's the, that's what the
Amazon one click. The beautiful,
the beauty is of Twitter and things like
that too, is I find out about new music.
I'll find out about news and different
things. Or if I'm in New York, you know,
I might just search. If I am, I'll
search. Oh, the city that I'm in,
I just started this city events and
I'll find out this person is playing a
concert. I didn't even know what
they have planned, a concert,
but I found out about it through
Twitter or just saying, hey,
what's the best restaurant here in Denver?
You have people give you restaurant
suggestions and then you'd go and
[inaudible] is great. So that's
the, that's the beauty of a,
of Twitter and the immediacy
of the Internet is that
access and just having that
information and being able to use it.
Fuck yeah. Um, I use, uh, because
I'm, I use an android phone. I use
Amazon. Yeah. And so, uh, I
use Amazon for, for music,
for comedy, for anything. And
I was coming home from, uh,
the Improv in Irvine and I said, I need
to hear some fucking new comedy. I'm like,
everybody keeps telling you this.
Hannibal Burress motherfuckers funny,
let me go check it out. So I got
this, I got animal furnace, dude,
it's fucking bad ass. And I got it
within 10 minutes, within 10 minutes,
I had it on my, on my
knee. I mean, not even,
I was driving and I was playing
it within like 30 seconds. Right.
And the whole thing was downloaded
within a couple of minutes just on,
I only had three g at the time.
I couldn't even get four g and boom,
it's on your phone and you're listening
while you're driving. It's amazing.
Ed is good to like issues with fas.
Like I had one where a specialist
Chicago, some of this, but yeah,
when I shot the special, uh, the
ticket price was kind of low,
so it got scalped Kinda have you got
scalped and scalp was well in lies.
I mean people writing me saying, uh, I
want to come to your show, but you know,
fuck it, I'm paying $200 for this
scalper and I was like, fuck that.
They'll pay 200 bucks.
You can donate to this charity,
mercy home and screen screen cap,
uh,
a a screencap to receipt showing that you
donate it and I'll put you on my guest
list. You know what I mean? But that's
just through Twitter. Twitter, I just be,
I just have angry fans.
Ryan's got,
it was probably still this
angry fans by scalped tickets,
but I was able to at least in a
couple situations with shows up,
it's sold out or shows the biggest scout.
I'm able to put somebody on
my guest list just cause they,
if they donate to that charity,
that's beautiful.
What's the charity with mercy home and
what is mercy home Diversey in Chicago is
this helps, uh, you know,
young black kids to Chicago,
just a w programs and says educates and
after school programs and things like
that.
That's amazing, man. That's a great
idea. That's a really great idea.
You are you from Chicago?
From Chicago because Ari Shaffir went,
we were in Chicago.
Ariana,
y'all went near town. It's the
same, yeah. UFC what's happened?
Yeah, we did the Chicago theater Friday
night and then already went and go,
went and checked you out.
Was it Friday night or Saturday night?
It was Saturday on that shot.
Yeah.
So he went and checked you out I think
after the fights were over. Yeah. Yeah.
I think he went there right after the
fights were over and checked out your
special, yeah. That's cool man.
Where'd you play in Chicago to visit?
So that was this show. That was this
show. Oh, so this is fresh, man.
This is fresh out of the box.
It's only a couple of months ago.
We turned it over fast. Fast. Was that,
when was it as a two area filled?
January 25th wow. Damn,
that's perfect though.
That way you get there. There'll probably
be some jokes on TV if they're topical.
Like do you have anything topical that
like, is that still applicable today?
Uh, nothing really topic. Let's
talk about music a little bit.
Current music and things like that,
but nothing political but the beach boys.
What's up the things to the beach boys
a lot. These fucking monkeys and
Duran Duran, they're so weird.
They always Duran Duran and
too sexy. The too, there's
something about him.
I don't like how symmetrical they are.
Yeah.
It's what I always appreciated about
Keith Richards and Mick Jagger.
They're kind of ugly to
kind of fucked up login.
I liked my music to come
out of some people that live
in the experience of pain.
Yeah. Bam, Bam, Wheaton.
It's impossible to avoid.
Gives us no first the right pitch for it.
It's a great picture. It's
the right picture for it.
You're smiling with your TV,
teeth, your eyes, Davey tape.
Um, so, uh, besides your
special, uh, where else can
people find your tour dates?
It's turned, I saw my website is Hannibal
buress.com. Um, I think, yeah. Yeah.
I only got a few days coming up while
I try to get this new shit together.
Yeah. Oh, that's right man.
That's the thing, right? Yeah.
You got to abandon the old and come up.
Let's Amanda. No, they'll go half and half
a sub. So I'm working on it, but yeah,
it Hannibal Buress Dotcom
and I'm in a, you know, on,
at the knitting factory in
Brooklyn on Sundays. Every Sunday.
Every Sunday if a less amount of role.
But this Sunday coming up I'm hosting. Oh,
that's right.
Cool. So you host dare, like, like you
were talking about doing shows where the,
you bring up your friends is that we,
yeah. Bring a friends and have
musical guests. Like, cause we have a,
we have a rent.
It's the front barn and we had a main
room that holds about 300 so that's what I
have a couple of musical
guests. Oh, that's awesome.
That's a great idea. So yes,
just act Bridget Everett this song. That's
amazing. Have you seen Bridget Everett?
No, no, no. He's just like just
sorta comedy, Cabaret Sing and act.
But like gets the crazy reaction from
the crowd. People split when they see it.
What would sort of, what's a unique about
it is just really good. Really good.
She's a good,
she's a great singer,
but then she also interacts with the
crowd in a way where she'll just put a
random crowd members face into her
titties was in the middle of a song and
she'll ride or walk around.
It's a, it's a crazy,
just is perfect live at I guess what
of those acts two where it's alive and
well, you could watch it on,
you might have videos up,
you could watch it and be like, oh, that's
cool. But you see her live, it's like, oh,
the shit watching people watch
is I like to watch out of the,
you know,
you see people's reaction.
I'm has some cats that only come and
usually see standard with my show,
but they are watching her like, what
the fuck is going on? But she's uh, eh,
she was real good. Uh, and
then got Michael Che on that
show right there. Yeah. Yes.
All right there.
Let me hear some of this.
Wow. What an aggressive woman. Not
a man. Can't handle that handle.
A lot of men get confused.
A woman like that.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
She's finds an audience dude and sits
in his lap and she's sweating all over.
And I bet that chick sweats a lot.
That's hilarious.
So you do this every Sunday. His show
is every Sunday. Whether I'm that. Yeah.
What made you decide to start
doing something like that?
How did you get that started?
It was when it was an old nine.
Uh,
I had just started writing for Saturday
night live and I did the opening night
at the native factor.
It used to be in downtown Manhattan
and it moved to Williamsburg, Brooklyn.
I did open night opening night there,
opening for this band, the savvy five.
And then they uh, the, the management,
they said we want to do a comedy night.
And so at the time I was writing
it Saturday night laughs.
So my only open night was a Sunday nights.
So I just started doing it and it,
and it's built over time with built an
audience. Like it used to be, you know,
patsy yard, he's like, you know,
it gets 20 people here at 30 feet,
but it's now it's packed all the time.
And a lot of people drop in
and Louie's been through.
Chris rock comes through a little bit.
Chappelle's been through
was Amy Schumer cubs,
like a lot of people
come through to work out.
It's a savvy crowds is high
energy and it's a lot of fun.
That's what I try out my new shit.
And this is kind of my,
it's two blocks from my place,
which is very convenient.
Oh Wow.
So you can walk to work,
walks out at nine o'clock show.
Sometimes I'm in the shower at eight 50
now. You told people though,
but this is the problem.
Now that freaks are going to get near
that area and scan out in a two block grid
and try to figure out where we're
Hannibal lives. I'm moving in.
Oh, started to going hunting. Shrimps.
I like the idea. You hosted a
show too. That's a great idea man.
That's what I'm in Boston.
That's what they used to do.
They used to have like
the Steve Sweeney show,
like the Boston headliners and that guy
would host and he would bring up all
these other comedians.
Fun. It's a way for me to kind
of stay, you know? Cause if you,
once you headline and
you just go on the road,
it's easy to kind of get out of
touch with who you know. So out.
It'd be comics that only been doing it
for a year on the same show with you know,
Chris rock or somebody. So it's good to
just see everybody and just, you know,
and just, you know, I still like the, the,
the structure of putting together a show,
just knowing I should have this person
on earlier and that a flow good and to
dance and this person should go
second half cause that. So I still,
I book it myself and everything.
So it's, it's, it's a lot of fun.
It's a good spot to just always,
always try new stuff there every week.
And it's a fun time.
Yeah, we do that out here at the Ice
House in Pasadena. If you ever around man,
we do a lot of like Wednesday night shows.
If you ever hear on a Wednesday
night and the same thing I'll,
it'll be me and I'll bring
along like Brian Cowan are,
you should fear Dunkin Joey deals look
good. Like all these different guys do it.
And having that same sort of situation
where you're trying to figure out who
should go on after him and put
him here and it's fun. Yeah.
What, it works out the right way
and you're like, oh, that feels,
it just feels good. It kind of producing
something all the time and just,
you know, figuring out
what, Yay. Who we was like,
what comics was the audience we
were spying on what comics to,
obviously we're a sponsor of that
kind of thing. This is real cool.
Yeah.
Like what you're doing too though.
You're adding know the musical element
to it too. That's a great idea.
Yeah. The music album, it's just
good for energy and it's just,
it's just mixing it up and
makes it more of a old school.
So lately I've been having kind
of raw rappers and musicians open,
open for me on the road in addition to
having a comedian. I have one comedian.
Yeah. I mean doing Largo tonight. And
uh, this cat, he just got done to cat.
It was amazing. Uh, singer
and basis, he's performing.
And so it's just been real.
It's just a different vibe.
And this adds another element
to the show. Also. I just want,
I like giving people,
I get,
I get just cause my ticket prices just
started to go up, so I feel nervous.
So I want to give people as much
as a so as possible. So I'm like,
I got to have a musician,
I have a DJ with me. Like,
cause I do musical stuff doing my set.
When I talk about different rap
songs to DJ or cue it up. I got,
I do a song at the end,
ballerinas come out outside of that.
Do people pay 30 bucks? I'm
trying to do it up. So, uh, yeah,
I enjoyed it. Is trying
to, you know, you know,
introduce people to introduce audiences
to new people and also just a freak out.
Just how to put on just a real a show
that people want to come back to it.
Like it's all about making
people want to talk about it.
And when I come back to this
city wanting to come again,
well you're doing it because I
keep hearing. Great. Thanks man.
I keep hearing great things.
Thanks man. And I've, uh,
I've only done one show everywhere.
I had music. There was a Joey Diaz,
me and Doug, Stan hope and
honey honey, this band that's a,
they're actually going to be here
tomorrow. Um, and we, uh, we all did this,
uh, show, uh,
at the Wiltern in La on December 21st,
2012 because it was supposed to be
the end of the world. Yeah. Yeah.
That was when the mines, all the fucking
freaky people were thinking that. It was,
it was a awesome night.
It was an awesome night,
but it was the only time I've ever been
fired. Oh, it's fucking beautiful show.
I wore a suit and everything. I never
wear a suit. I wore slick clothes.
Felt odd, but I liked it, but
it felt good. Like, you know,
it was fun to do like a big show to
musical guests. I got to do more of those.
Yeah. It's just adds a acid, another
energy to it. Especially if the crowd is,
is that they go about doing it is just
making sure that the music economy could
work as long as people are a little bit,
it could work as a surprise,
but when people I built
it makes it better,
especially for the comedian opening for
a band and you walk out as a comedian
for a band and they don't
know that you're covered,
I guess is the word I years ago open
for this band unfree Mcgee's uh,
and we, it was, I took the
Gig was in Dekalb, Illinois.
It was about our outside,
Chicago's what? Northern Illinois
University is one of the band.
They saw me as xannies in Chicago Comedy
Club and they asked me to open for them
and so it was at,
I think they were on at nine and then at
45 they tell me to go and the lights go
down. And so there's been no
announcement that I'm going on.
It's just the lights went
down and then I walk out.
Crowd is like right away. Like
no, like they just started yelling
and it's not even the real showtime yet.
I'm up 15 minutes before
the actual start time.
I was the only open it but people were
just so agitated because they didn't want
to see a comedian.
They they you know,
bought these tickets probably months ago
and then some comedian they never heard
of is walking out so but it just
helps with just the audience.
So all of the [inaudible]
cause they didn't know either.
The band is just trying to put me
in a good spot. They were like,
we like this dude,
he used to be on the show and now I'm
known from doing shows that situation like
that all it takes is for
somebody from the bands,
either side stays on the mic
or even come out and say,
hey we are going to be
out in a little bit.
We got this commedia we like
check them out we think is funny.
And then that settles everything down
because now that gives me credibility.
So it's just about the audience,
knowing what's going on and then that
that makes everything work easier.
When I bring people on the road with me,
I always introduce them from the SAS.
I always say thank you
everybody for coming out. Yeah.
Yell out and just get everybody
hyped up and let them know. Like,
I'm sure I'm bringing this comedian
because I think he's hilarious.
I want you to see good shit.
Yeah. Some cats, the
people have open floor.
I've done that flow besides days
like Dimitri done that Aziz, uh,
Louis, it just helps subside
GAF. Like it just helps it, uh,
especially as,
I mean,
your crowds might be a little bit
more aggressive to some mothers. No,
they're nice. They're nice, but you don't
show sometime man. It'll still show some,
let's do a show. That's awesome, man.
Yeah. Um, I opened up
for Bon Jovi once. Yeah.
I was in a theater in the round in,
I think it was in queens and it was,
I'm a long time ago. Yeah, it was two.
It was ridiculous. I was, first of all,
I wasn't that good.
I had only been doing comedy for
like four years and a second.
Second of all, it was they didn't
want to see a comedian, you know,
it just was a terrible idea.
The whole idea was awful.
And I'm standing on this fucking stage
surrounded by like a drum set and guitar.
I can't move. I didn't know
where to stand. It was a,
Oh was the,
was the uh,
what are the people like the rodeo 80
by was there moving around fixing shit
behind you.
100% subsides and music gets with it.
Comedians out data respect that
it's still fixing the sound.
They might even bang on the drums a
little bit. Check the guitar, no doubt.
Check things, check the
drums, don't give a fuck.
They don't care about you.
They just like I'm done.
I'm trying to do my job the best way
possible. It's fuck you and your up.
Yeah.
It was just bizarre man.
It was just bizarre being on a stage
when nobody wants you to be doing comedy.
Like they want you to go out there and
do comedy for people who didn't want to
come see comedy.
There's a totally different mindset
going to see Bon Jovi and some unknown
shithead tell bad jokes.
Yeah. Waiting for Bon Jovi.
They also wanted me to
like work the crowd.
Like they wanted me to bring
women up towards the front.
They wanted me to grab the most attractive
women and ask them to come towards
the front.
They wanted to like sort of engineer
the front in the middle of your bombing.
Exactly.
The middle of me eating Dick and,
and there wasn't that many
attractive women in the first place.
It was like picking the ones
who were attractive was,
it wasn't the best job.
So were you able to do that at all?
I did something. I mean it was a long time
ago. It was a disaster, whatever it was.
I remember getting out of there going,
okay,
now I know what it's like to
open up for our band. Fuck that.
And that was a nice crowd as far as
like bands go, that's a nice crowd.
I just was terrible.
I shouldn't have been doing it.
I've had gigs with, there's isn't
that, I've done gigs recently.
Over the past year would have
been horrible gigs with music,
but I just bailed early. Like if I could
feel it in the first couple of jokes,
like, all right, this is the
fun. Y'all have a good one.
I we you still doing it?
Like somebody called you up today
and asked you to open up for a band.
Would you still do it? It depends
on the band. If I'm, I won't do it.
It had to be a favor and just something,
if it was a charity thing or if
the money's right, like I, I,
I'm not just going to turn down a
gig because of it being for a band.
It has to be, yeah. I have
to ask some questions.
Well, it's getting also as a point
where people know who you are too,
so they come see you and the band
they expect you and the band.
That's part of the hope program.
That makes a lot more sense then.
Yeah, just me kind of flounder and in
front of it. But I think it's, and it's,
it's been two or three gigs where I just
said, you know what, I'm Outta here.
Y'All caught me. Like my name was
Hannibal Burress see how later.
Like I would even good because this
is like, you know what the Gig wasn't.
It wasn't right, but I don't, I know it.
There's no bearing on what I could do.
It just wasn't the right situation. Did
you ever see the one with Charlie Murphy,
uh, toward the checkup? He didn't really
say that checkout well, he didn't.
He didn't. I don't think
he, I do know for sure.
I think I remember look at it up more.
I think he kept that check and I
was a show. I don't know. I know,
I know Charlie, he's kind of crazy.
He to definitely tear up a chalk,
especially if you had money and he's got
money to tear up a chart and tell you,
go fuck yourself. It's got a
lot of character. Well, Scott,
balls of steel.
I'm the type of dude I tear up a check
and then have my agent asked, but a wire
on second thought, can you sit in that
to this routing number, please? Yeah.
That's probably the more intelligent
way of doing it. It's fake.
Just tear up a piece of paper fucking
checks. Why? Think about your money.
Yeah,
a symbolic check.
Yeah. Hannibal, you're funny, mother
fucker. Thank you very much for having me.
This was, this was real cool. I
enjoyed it very much, man. Okay.
Hannibal Burress go uh,
to Hannibal burress.com you can follow
Hannibal on Twitter and definitely either
download it from comedy central
or watch it this Saturday night.
What time is it on again?
Selling at midnight,
midnight eastern and midnight
Pacific and 11 central.
And download it now if you want.
I liked the name to live from Chicago.
Can Fuck around.
Why fuck around this hubcap shop
in my old neighborhood. Oh really?
Yeah, a hubcap shops still around. Yeah.
Hubcaps sat phone on North Avenue and
Chicago. All right, that's it folks.
We'll be back tomorrow.
We got two podcasts tomorrow.
Adam Carolla and honey honey.
And then Friday.
It's Dennis Dennis Mckenna on Friday.
So we've got a,
we've got a lot of crazy shit this
week. Um, thanks to naturebox.
Thanks to naturebox,
go to naturebox.com/rogan and
get 50% off your first box.
Thanks also to Onnit got.com go to o.
N n I t.
Use the codeword Rogan and save 10%
off any and all supplements. All right,
we'll see you dirty freaks. Uh,
tomorrow. Uh, oh. April 3rd, I will
be at the Fillmore in
Miami beach with Tony. Uh,
Hinchcliffe. And then, um,
how else am I? April, um,
Orlando. Yeah. April 18th, I'm in Orlando.
And the 23rd. What's the other one? The,
yeah, 25th. I'm in Baltimore, both of
those with Joey Dhea. So Orlando is,
uh, the 18th. Go to Joe
rogan.net for tickets. The um,
Orlando's almost sold out and
Baltimore's almost sold out as well,
but it's still some tickets left for
Miami. All right, you freaks. We love you.
We'll see you tomorrow.
Big Kiss.